wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn the number one skill for getting
rich how to fix your money mindset the
step-by-step process to pile up money
while you sleep and Timeless investing
strategies get ready to uncover your
strategies for success and accumulate
massive wealth
enjoy hello and welcome to episode 9 of
wealth breakthroughs let's get right
into it today we've got an action-packed
episode first up is Michael bernoff
founder of the human Communications
Institute he's going to show you why 99%
of people will never become wealthy no
matter how hard they work he's also
going to show you how to make sure
you're part of the 1% that amasses
significant wealth and he's going to
reveal the number one skill anyone
seeking real lasting wealth should
master your personal wealth breakthrough
could be in this interview with Michael
watch it
[Music]
closely when Michael having seen you
speak multiple times before I know we're
in for a very Lively conversation it's
going to be this is going to be fun so
let's talk about how did you a boy from
Jersey yeah like me two of us two of us
right how did you end up doing what
you're doing what was your path uh pain
pain I I say it all the time to people
pain I went into business for myself and
I thought it would be easy I had a
couple of great parents that you know
mom's a teacher dad's an engineer and
you know I they said that everybody that
did well had a business nobody showed me
how to do it so I went into business
with their whole attitude of you know
work hard be a good person and failed
miserably at it right off the bat so
when I found you go to college yeah I
went to college I went to college but in
college this is this is crazy so I had a
guy introduced me to direct sales and
network marketing at 17 years old I got
started as an entrepreneur right in
college one of the guys that actually
founded Under Armour is the guy that
introduced me I didn't realize until
years later this guy um I name is wood
he one of the founders of Under Armour
introduced me to a direct sales company
and I was hustling stuff you know I knew
how to talk I could I could I knew the
shtick I could get people to do things
but I didn't really have the long-term
stick in what I was doing mhm so then
you got out of college you went into
your own business failed miserably I was
almost not going to finish school I
someone gave me Rich Dad Poor dead book
and literally looked at it and they're
like entrepreneur it was really for me
so it was like one semester left add um
have my own little business on the side
still failing miserably at it but
wanting to figure out how to do it and I
had to like force myself to finish
school but when I finished um when I
finished I never really went to work for
anybody else it was one of those things
I've always said I wanted to figure it
out so it was a teacher in college that
changed my life I remember I failed out
of Arizona state for a semester real did
a good job went for um you know it took
me five and a half years to get out and
at Mesa Community College I took an
interesting sales class see couldn't get
into the business school at ASU never
got in i m graduated the communications
degree but uh one of the teachers handed
me a book and a list of books you could
read anything from The Wealth of Nations
to this and one was how to INF friends
and influence people and literally got
the book I'm a single guy um How to Win
Friends Influence People I'm 19 years
old and that book opened myself up to
the idea of you can actually learn
yourself better I had no idea that I
thought I was stuck with what I had in
life I thought I'd work hard and that
book taught me the biggest shortcut in
the world that you can learn from others
how to get what you want wow so where
did that lead you then so you're you
you're failing into business failing in
business had a couple of business didn't
work out and then when I found personal
development when I found the ability to
work on myself to understand the problem
was up here that the reason I wasn't
making the money I wanted the reason I
wasn't getting ahead the way I wanted
was sitting up here in my head it was
one little meeting that I was at in
California there was a gentleman named
Tom and he was a a pet safety guy of all
things and he walked up to me and he
goes that was a great presentation I'm
like actually that was a sales pitch
because you guess didn't work well
because nobody bought anything he goes
you got a great presence have you ever
heard of neural linguistic programming
and he goes I used to work with you know
this guy back in the day or you you you
got a great thing about yourself but I
wasn't listening to him and he he's the
guy that geared me towards understanding
communication so he has never actually
went extremely far with the stuff but
he's the guy that actually got me
started with two people one was a book
and number two was a guy just nudged me
and sometimes the littlest things nudge
us and they they wake us up so you're
talking a lot about heads space now
saying that you discovered that you know
this is your heads space can really
change your life your outcomes Etc
changed everything so do you think that
the primary determinant of the ability
to uh create wealth um is headp space I
would say the primary ability to create
wealth in your life is based on a little
something which I would call your
average and I think most people in life
they are living an average life and I
don't mean you versus somebody else I
believe that you get to a point in your
life even when you're doing well I've
seen people that make a lot of money but
they're not wealthy right and I've seen
people that are broke and they're
definitely not wealthy and what I've
recognized is most people are the way
they've set up their life their
automatic autopilot they have for their
life is to get about what they have
right now and anything else they want is
a dream as a hope as a wish and wanting
it is so exciting and turns them on so
much wanting it that actually having it
isn't really in the equation yeah
meaning that they're always just
pursuing they're pursuing and the idea
of wanting it isn't part of their
current ident wanting it's part of their
current identity actually having it
getting over the wall to literally get
from where you are to where you want to
go is people's biggest challenge and
it's the mind it's our actions it's our
attitude but most people aren't aign to
be able to actually do that
so how do they get AI somebody's
watching us saying you know what I'm
where you were you I'm struggling you
know I'm failing miserably I but I feel
like I want to be an entrepreneur I I
want to you know create good income or
wealth and uh but I I find these blocks
how do I how do I clear them out how do
I get my heads there's a few things to
work on I always I figure if you're
going to be put in a box you might as
well have a metaphor of what that box
really is so for me I always think the
box is the I'll never go back there
again box and I think the reason this
thing typically gets created it's a
really good idea for you finally make a
little extra money you get out of a
relationship you shouldn't be in and you
say I'll never do that again I believe
people build our wall of what we want a
little too um a little too far out
instead of recognizing that we need to
get where it is we need to go but this
is where the biggest challenge comes in
for most people it's in our identity
it's how you see you that is the biggest
challenge so number one is to really
change what your identity is and how you
see you and how you perceive what it is
you're doing I think most people are
wanting to do that and I know the whole
law of like Law of Attraction and just
wish it wish shit's going to be there
that's cute and all but to actually get
yourself to be a person that does it
there's a few things you have to change
and one of those to accept that you
actually have people in your life right
now that cheer you on for being who you
are the biggest thing I'd say is this
one one very simple word most people
getting what they want is negotiable and
one of the terms I use all the time is
non-negotiable so getting what you want
has to start to become non-negotiable
and part of that is actually working on
what it is that you want so I know the
whole personal development space is
don't talk about the word want because
want means not having but you actually
have to work on what you want and
understand there's a major disparity
between what you have what you want and
what are these like dream board dreams
that are way out there I feel that if
most people actually were getting what
they wanted maybe not their Ultimate
Dream they'd be satisfied so what we
need to do is to enhance our identity of
how we see ourselves and start getting
pieces of what we're looking for in our
lives so does this tie into uh the idea
of what your average that's the whole
average yeah that's that's my whole
average thing I mean that's the whole
average sucks I mean that's the point of
everything and I I wear my shirts all
the time i' say average sucks and people
look at me like um they look at me and
they say you know so you're telling me
like you know you're right average sucks
you know I'm better than them it has
nothing to do with me versus you it's
you versus your average like so the
question is for most people like when
someone says Michael like how tall am I
and I'm 6 foot6 and years ago a buddy
poked me he goes how tall are you I I'm
6'6 he goes you really just start to act
like it and he goes most people really
act about 5' 6 and they're maybe 510 or
they act 5'1 and the reason is we're
only playing a piece of ourselves and
we're getting away with it and the
reason is we're comfortable we're
comfortable with where we're at so by
raising what your average is like most
people's income is about the same every
year um they get about the same amount
of money and what's fascinating is
anyone watching doesn't have to work as
hard as they are they'll wind up in the
same place anyways you could sit on your
ass for nine months of the year in the
last um 90 days of the year your gears
will kick in you'll start to do it
you'll get super excited about it
because you know that's who you are
you're the person that actually does
that thing earns that amount of money to
get the amount of money you want means
you're gonna have to learn to change
your average and part of that is really
starting to create new non-negotiables
for yourself starting to put things in
your life and make them necessary for
you to do give me an example like some
non-negotiables that somebody might
change my like income sounds like one
saying you know I'm used to making
$100,000 a year and I find a way no
matter what whether I lose a job I'm in
business uh you know ups and downs the
economy I still find a way to get to
that 100,000 and you're right it really
I think people do somehow migrate to an
expectation that they have consciously
or unconsciously so how conscious is
somebody's average versus you know
unconscious average I don't think
anybody really thinks about it people
weigh about the same amount of weight
every year or within a course of five
years or 10 years everything averages
out it's fascinating you have just about
same amount of fights every year based
on what your conversations are what
you're doing so to answer to answer the
question and keep it simple just give an
example like let's just say um we got
cameras around let's say somebody's
watching this to us you know I always
want wanted to be a photographer I I got
a job I work at a I work at a company I
make decent money well you got a dream
of being a photographer you don't have a
camera you don't have any clients you
have nothing one of the things we need
to learn is how to jump over the
metaphoric wall to go to the other side
and start actually doing what it is you
want to be doing years ago I had a guy
that worked at Motorola give it an
example and he came to came to me and
came to one of our events and he said
Michael I want to I want to start to be
a um I want to start to be a
photographer one day and I'm like you
got a great income I said do you want to
equipment he goes no I I don't own any
equipment so I said why to go do that so
he jumps over the wall buys equipment
now he's a guy that actually owns a
camera and then one day he says Hey I
want to shoot a birthday party make a
hundred bucks shooting a kid's clown
party so he jumps over the wall shoots a
clown party it's non-negotiable
eventually unfortunately this guy got
laid off the economy went down Motorola
laid off a bunch of people the guy now
is forced to actually have to make this
work so now he's doing parties and
weddings and bar mitzvah and everything
and he's working on it and he started to
make it non-negotiable for ourselves we
need to work on what it is that we want
and stop dreaming about it and we have
to be willing to do the little teeny
things along the way so when I think of
wealth wealth creation for most people I
think the relationship with money is
part of their Challenge and the
relationship with their average I mean I
told a guy once I said you're not going
to save your way rich but if you start
respecting money like the fact that you
avoid Starbucks you know it's seven
bucks a drink here you are wanting money
but you're going there three times a day
I had a had a limo driver he wants to go
see his dad over in Africa right for the
summer I said where do you spend your
money you know not able to go and he
goes well I goes to Starbucks he goes
three times a day plus the pound kick
spending 50 bucks a day going to
Starbucks this guy I said why don't you
just transfer $20 it's changing this is
going to get you rich but transferring
$20 from your your checking account to
your savings account that's all I'm
going to ask you to do make the transfer
every single day just have it automatic
that it does automatically so on a
savings basis it changes his average
right it changes his average he got to
me a couple months later he goes Michael
I have $1,600 I said it's not going to
change everything but it changed your
relationship with money you're actually
starting to respect it and most people
don't have really respect for money they
don't have a great relationship with it
they don't understand it they don't know
where it comes from it's not important
to them most people that aren't doing
well financially they have zero books in
their house on wealth they have zero
friends that are making the amount of
money they want to make and they're not
surrounding themselves with an
appropriate relationship when it comes
to money so those are I think two
important uh Dimensions one is like you
said uh you know what are you reading
meaning what are you feeding your mind
and then two who are you surrounding
yourself with
so so talk can you speak a little bit
more about each of those yeah I mean
what you're reading I mean that that's
the thing I mean I remember Jim rone was
one of my earliest mentors I had years
ago when he was when he was alive he was
like my my dad and then that was like my
business dad and he would teach me
everything about money and he said you
actually are living the life that you're
choosing right now and I realized I had
no money and he said that that's your
choice and that's what you're doing and
a lot of times that's a hard pill to
swallow so if you did you resent that at
first I hated it okay understand it yeah
cuz you if you were like if somebody's
watching us right now yeah we're saying
them you know you don't you don't want
to be rich you don't want money and
they're like what are you talking about
it's so how did you received that and
when did you finally realize it was
right I get it now um it's hard to
accept that when you're in a situation
um I always tell everyone if you had
more money you'd have nothing to
and complain about right so and then
you'd be bored because people's favorite
thing is to and complain right so
that's your favorite thing I mean if I
ask you to eliminate complaining for
well not you you don't complain and I
don't complain either because we like to
talk about big things and that's the
thing wealthy people they talk about big
things all of friends that we know they
talk about big things stuff that stuff
that's happening in the world that's
making it happen but if you stop
complaining about your problems for a
month right you'd have no friends left
because that's what people talk about
they complain so when I first heard that
I didn't like it and then I recognized
that in order to make more money I
needed to First accept I didn't have
enough and that is one of the most
painful things for people to do but once
you get through that pain like chapter
two of our book is on adversity and we
say that the biggest challenge in the
world today is people aren't very good
at dealing with everyday adversity
because life has gotten super easy right
Little House in the prairie back in the
day when um P was out there I don't
think he was bitching about going to the
gym right he wasn't planning like I'm
having trouble getting a Lifetime
Fitness because he worked out he was out
there he had to learn how to survive you
people people we don't have adversity
life's easy kids are getting food
delivered to the house getting delivered
to their school these days so life has
gotten real easy so is marketer ability
to take our money so it's very hard to
get ahead so we've got a lot of info
against us so we need to empower
ourselves better so back trct to what I
was saying a minute ago about uh what
Jim originally said that you're living
the life that you're choosing to live it
was hard to hear but he also said how
many books do you have on being wealthy
and I had thinking Grow Rich and I was
broke I had the magic of thinking big
and I thought small and I like to
complain a lot and I realized that I
didn't understand thinking Grow Rich I
didn't understand that the book is in
the title you don't even need to read
the book right change your thinking
you've got a chance to Grow Rich right
change your thinking you can get wealthy
yep okay so that's interesting saying
hey you know what are you reading what
are you what are you putting in your
mind and that helps really create
mindset books have totally changed my
mindset just reading books now talk
about who you hang out with because the
old adage uh you are like the five
people you hang out with most is that
true it's massively true and it's their
expectations you take on you take on
their expectations you take on their
standards and a lot of times we we play
to the weakest link not and to the
strongest link so I like to be the
weakest link and that's why I attempt to
surround myself with as much as possible
people they don't have to be wealthy
there's different levels of wealth I
that are billionaires um they're some of
those fun people in the world and
they're very cheap some of them I have
friends that are absolutely horrible
with money they make 300 Grand a year
and they spend $450,000 a year I have
friends that make millions and um
they've got good Liv some of them are
married some of them are happy but the
wealthiest people the ones that have
what it is you want and their
relationship with money is the one you
want it to be so if you don't have
somebody like that in your life one of
the first things you can do is you can
have audio mentors you can watch things
like this you can get around those
people and start modeling their
behaviors figure out what they're doing
that's a big step in the right direction
for people you speak a lot about
persuasion and you're you're really an
expert in that world and I've heard you
present on that one of my favorite
things yeah well and you do it I mean
it's it's an extraordinary presentation
that you have on that or series of
presentations is there a relationship
between wealth development and
persuasion the only way to get where you
want in this world is through
communication money comes from other
people and money comes from
relationships that's where it comes from
so let's get really clear that commun
ation is the most underdeveloped and
underutilized asset we have as human
beings and is the fastest way to get
what you want in this world if you need
a loan you have to communicate with the
bank that they need to give that to if
we're selling right now and you have a
business you need to sell I need to
communicate why my product do value as a
as a doctor you need to communicate why
they need to come back again which
brings in money so all money comes in a
form of communication and it is the most
underdeveloped thing in the world a big
sign at my office says your future
hinges on your ability to effectively
communicate
really think I should change that to
your wealth hinges on your ability to
effectively communicate to get what it
is you want and I believe were very
misspoken I had had a guy come in the
office the other day young kid just
graduated from college entrepreneurship
I said how many classes have you taken
on communication one one in four years I
ask doctors how many classes they've
taken on communication and they're
having trouble financially no classes
you can graduate from Palmer or east or
west or any chiropractic school in the
world and not take one class
uninfluenced communication which is the
most fascinating thing in the world so I
believe that people can get there a lot
quicker if they can learn how to
influence other people but also
influence themselves so this guy comes
into the office and um the person doing
the hire in the office asks the question
what type of income are you currently
accustomed to MH kid says I don't know
what do you want to pay me she turns
around and says to him whether we hire
you or not will be one thing but whoever
you ever talk to again and they ever ask
you that question let me help you
reframe that because the difference is
whether you're getting 25 Grand a year
or 100 Grand a year is how you answer
that question did it sink in he got it
and waiters and waitresses are a great
place to practice you know what kind of
tip would you like I don't know whatever
you feel like giving I'm very obvious
like guy says 100 bucks I'll give it to
him say a, bucks I'll give it to him
I've done that before it's a wealthy
mindset yeah so here's what's
interesting now you talk about
communication persuasion I guess is is
the is the cousin or the the they're
closely related closly related so here's
the question you hear terms like well
he's got or she's got the gift of Gab
yep what I'm hearing from you is that no
this is a skill that can be developed
and learned it's not like either you
have it or you don't is that accurate
what's your premise I mean there's a lot
of things that happen from birth you
could walk out of the womb and you're I
came out with my legs were crooked I was
born I cast to my legs like far as Gump
when I was a kid and I got out of that
you know some people they their breathe
correctly when they're born some people
wind up being more effective you grow up
in Jersey you got to talk just to speak
it's part of to get a word in my
household you have to but the funny
thing is people don't recognize in their
in their Hometown I mean if you want to
get ahead you go to Toast Masters you
can spend a hundred bucks a year you can
probably convince the guy to let you
come for free he'll clean the floors to
spend 50 imagine 52 weeks a year you did
that you want to get ahead like most
people don't recognize that if you even
were a better Communicator at your job
you'd make more money you could take
that extra money and create wealth with
it buying real estate doing something on
the side reinvesting that money he or
she who communicates effectively the
wealthiest companies in the world are
communication companies if you think
about Steve Jobs you created a
Communications company that's all Apple
really is all Microsoft is a
Communications company how to get
material out to people tme the
wealthiest guy in Mexico at one point is
a Communication company so I believe
anybody can learn communication but
you'd have to know it's a problem first
and not just say to yourself well you
know my problem is um I'm not good with
people you don't even need to be good
with people to be a good communicator
you have to understand people and and be
willing to understand human psychology
so are there some fundamental things
that like let's say okay I've never
taken a course in communication most
people haven't so likelihood is people
watching this haven't either no most
people haven't yeah so uh what are some
of the maybe the basics or fundamentals
like are are there maybe like a common
mistakes that people make or some
principles that they should learn most
people have to understand life is not
about getting people to like you and
that's where I think most people go
wrong and if you want to get ahead in
sales or business it's about willing to
be risk the relationship if you want to
get ahead in your own relationship you
have to be willing to risk and say will
you marry me you have to be able to let
you personally but you know what I'm
saying will you marry me or being able
to walk up to somebody and say I think
you need to buy this product and what
that is is momentarily the relationship
gets risked for a chance for it to be
even better you got to risk your muscle
to make your muscle better you have to
risk your money to make your money
better it's not about a home run I had
years ago the guy wasn't communicate
with me correctly I came into a little
bit extra money I was maybe 22 years old
I had 30 grand and I thought I was rich
you know I 30 grand now was like um you
know you could blow that on a weekend in
in in Cabo and and not not even on
drinks and just just being out there
just going to stand a nice place and I
went called the financial guy and I said
to the guy I said can you make this
money to more money and I said what are
you planning on wanting to do with it
and he said I said can you make it more
and I'm young kid I'm like can you just
I heard that there were people that can
get me more money can you he goes I have
a fiduciary your responsibility I need
to know what you want to do with it do
you want to save it to pay back loans do
you want to buy a house one day I'm like
no just make it more and he goes I
cannot take you on as a client and I
realized I don't think people have a
clear path of what they want to do with
their money or they want what how little
people need to impact themselves like
most people want to get like 100% return
on their money they want get a th%
return if you could find a way to get
eight or 10% every eight years in your
money your money doubles and that's the
part most people don't realize they
looking for this large thing instead of
realizing the secret is inconsistency
yeah and getting okay with being
peaceful with the idea that 8% for most
people over a course of a long enough
period of time you can double triple
quadruple your money overnight Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam and then you have extra
money when you find a big opportunity
that that can make you a th% return do
something big you got the cash ready to
do it right what are some of the bigger
lessons you've learned then around money
I guess that's one of them saying hey
you know it's it's more of a a
consistency game than trying to make big
hits uh the big hits will get you killed
I I've never have you ever met anyone
that the big hits really worked out for
consistently I've had big hits I've met
people who got lucky and I've gotten
lucky sometimes but you know I I thought
I was smart and that was the problem
like my the first time I bought a piece
of commercial real estate I almost you
know better and tripled it with within
about four years when I sold it and I'm
like I'm a real estate genius and then I
I then I lost on the next three Deals
I'm like oh I was lucky propagon
propagon propagon yeah I see that all
the time it's like being out at a town
like I remember being younger and being
out one night like hey let's reprod
let's reproduce last night again tonight
and you try as hard as you can night2
sucks you can't reproduce it so looking
for the Home Run is one of the biggest
issues I I believe the biggest thing is
education and educating yourself and
taking a minute to understand wealth and
understand what wealthy people do they
do different things they have I remember
watching this thing on Warren Buffett
he's got a free calendar he spends a lot
of time thinking yeah he's very very
concerned with keeping his thoughts
clear in his head and getting around the
right kind of people and keeping a
really open schedule to hear about
opportunities and he's listening all the
time to high level opportunities he's
also got the right voices in his head so
when you ask me when it comes to wealth
or it comes to creating finances of
herself I I've recognized that there
isn't just one way and you have to look
at the overall picture so I'd say the
first thing is really to change your
relationship with money and stop having
it be something that you want and start
being something that you're beginning to
create and how you create it is just
looking at where you're at I mean just
accepting like taking a minute like if
you're not willing to take five minutes
and go here's where I'm really at here's
how much I have coming in here's what I
have going out I never wanted to do that
but if you don't take a minute and
figure out where you're at how on Earth
are you going to figure out where you're
going it's no reality in a sense cuz
some people like it's it's like you you
want to ignore that I don't want to know
not going to balance anything yeah yeah
it's like almost in in a sense you the
example you gave of the driver who was
spending all this money on Starbucks
probably wanted to ignore how much money
per day he was spending on Starbucks 50
bucks a day putting it right here in his
ballot yeah so so it's like you know
coming face to face with that it's like
saying okay now I have to change my
relationship here I got to become
conscious basically is what it amounts
to it sounds like if you if you can
respect your own influence and
understand that you have a chance to
impact the people around you and as
parents we have an obligation to teach
our children who are do not anything
about money we have messed them up
completely just by life being so easy we
should make it harder for them but we
have an obligation to people if you
could accept the power of your own
influence that your kids Do What You Do
by being able to risk the relationship
and saying you know what we're not
getting a Starbucks today or we're not
going out to dinner today and being able
to reallocate that money is enormous and
that's what you mean by risk the
relationship basically say that that you
might um upset somebody it's not like
you'll never talk to your kids again but
saying I might cause somebody I care
about to be upset by doing something
that is going to be uh posit posi for
their future yes yeah or for their
mindset or for their head space as far
as saying hey they need to they need to
get out of being numb and become more
conscious of what's going on around
we're pretty numb as people and we're
following the wrong group yeah it's not
complicated you're just following the
wrong crowd I mean I'm just going to
tell you like if you look at what
wealthy people do like when the economy
was shot we'd go to mastros and with
nice steakhous and it's busy all the
time yeah Chile isn't filled up um but
MOS is filled that you know $1,000
dinner and people are still going to
Napa they're still spending money maybe
the big people are not the ones that hit
the the one home run like the commercial
real estate Geniuses that both of us
have been maybe that person didn't have
home run but the people that created
consistency they weren't even um they
weren't even like um didn't even bother
them but I think also we get obsessed
and I the wrong kind of obsession I
think people get where it's something
that they want so bad that they build it
up in their head and they build it up as
this big thing for years I ink did an
article on me and um I talked about
perception and people talk about what
they want with their life especially
wealth and they talk about this big
house and on the hill you know big home
big house you know overlooking the ocean
or the ski slopes or whatever it is and
they picture their kids being happy in
the nicest Gucci of tire and
Lamborghinis in the driveway and I'm
like well where are you in the picture
they're like didn't think of putting
myself there I said what did you die and
they got the life insurance money I mean
what happened and being able to put
yourself in the picture meaning being
there with it and also building some of
the challenges in advance I like to
build that stuff in like so when I build
a timeline for my life I build
trampolines and trap doors I build like
how am I going to get rid of this job
down the road how am I going to get rid
of this thing that's going to bother me
a trampoline that's going to get me over
one of these hurdles and I I build at a
timeline of and I like to see my
challenges in advance and me beating
them before I get through them so when
they show up yeah I destroy them and
that's what big companies do they they
have contingency plans and I think most
people aren't prepared for a contingency
plan so one thing shows up boom knocks
them over but if you could be ready go
oh that's what Patrick was talking about
my real estate deal I screwed up on one
of those look I'm halfway there then and
you're one of us yeah so given that
backdrop that you just gave what is your
definition of wealth you know how would
you describe wealth was it mean to you
it's changed uh it's changed massively
you asked me when I was 22 it was 100
gazillion dollars uh you know I didn't
have you know all these kind of stuff
now wealth to me is not worrying about
money getting to a point where way more
than enough is coming in and structuring
my life to make my life work for me and
that's the thing so your wealth amount
could be 200 Grand your wealth amount
could be $ 35 gazillion doll
I have no interest in being Bill Gates I
have no interest in being Steve JS
that's not used to be my dream I have no
interest in traveling that much I don't
even like being on a plane that much but
what I do like is not having to worry
about money and my life working the way
I wanted to time with my kids never
missing a kids sport even in my life I'm
very wealthy right now I have money in
the bank my money makes money we did
very well last year um I own buildings I
own real estate I own properties I got
Sate mechanisms going all at once that
are producing wealth for me and my job
is to how can I do what I love all the
time and have money coming in regardless
was it a gradual change going from
because very similar in a sense of you
know in younger years the Ambitions as
far as you know those you yeah the you
the billionaire Ambitions right and then
uh but over time that really does at
least for for me it did and it sounds
like for you it changes quite a bit and
it sounds like uh you know having some
sense of security yep and having
fulfillment is really you know kind of
the D the dimension of wealth for you at
this point was there a sudden
realization or was it kind of a gradual
process for you um I'd say it was
gradual and matured you know you get
married you have kids things change I me
that's the one thing people don't
recognize and having children
immediately changes then your needs
change and the things that matter to you
change immediately so back when you're
single and you want to impress everybody
I wanted money to impress people now I
want money for lifestyle and to leave a
legacy and to be an example for my kids
and to be able to support them in in a
in in a way that they can have what they
want and have what they need and and
help them out so it changed over time
but in the last seven or eight years
been married uh eight nine years and uh
almost this year be nine coming up and
what's what's interesting is after being
after being in a relationship and having
a relationship with money where we're on
the same page and that's another thing I
think people are have to be willing to
have the relationship with someone they
love have that tough conversation to get
on the same page you want the most
detrimental way to lose and Napoleon
Hill does talk about thinking to go Rich
be married to the wrong idea with the
wrong person it's not even the person
need to get rid of you need to get clear
with them so you're on the same page
she's out spending he's out spending
you're out doing get clear on your
vision together is Big so my my gradual
progression I would say it came in when
I started to get serious about investing
um I went from a saver to an investor
yeah and I had a lady that was vetting
us for years to help us with our money
and I met her at a at a seminar very
wealthy and she only works with people
in our industry people that are making a
difference she fired all of her
corporate clients she hated she only
works with people people that are high
level and that are that are care that
she enjoys working with and her first
thing is Michael I want to get rid of
things you don't need to be spending
money on let's clean it all up let's
teach you about the benefit of life
insurance let's teach you all these
things so wealth came in with me
starting to educate myself but also I
would say in that move changed
everything went from an investor to now
owning commercial real estate to doing
our events in our own buildings right
now instead of having to go rent hotels
so now make saving hundreds of thousands
of dollars a year reinvesting that money
so it was in a decision to just get
consistent and really care that was a
weird breaking open that I had you know
it sounds like the one of the principles
that I've heard uh you know through
doing this series is that you earn your
money uh by you know the work you do
your income but you become wealthy
through investing 100% And so you agree
with that premise you'll never get
wealthy I hear it all the time I sat
with a guy the other day and I know this
he's like oh I said looked at the guy 33
years old he's making uh 1015 million a
year he's investing everything back in
his business I said are you saving some
he goes yeah you know I got a couple
hundred grand on the side I said I said
look I know you want to invest back in
your business for the 400% returns
you're getting but what if something
happens here you have nothing set up
over here and he's like not listening
and that used to be me yeah I did that a
100 times and now I'm realizing I'm
building multiple entities in financial
wealth management for myself that are
making a big difference so you got to
you got to put in your Sweat Equity you
got to put in your 10,000 hours you got
to get good at what you do if that's
what you want but there's also a great
way to get ahead I I've seen people you
know work on paying off their home
quicker and they pay off their home
quicker they stop eating out they pay
off their home quicker they wind up
saving $2,000 extra dollars a month
reallocate that into real estate rent it
to their neighbors 10 years later
they're a millionaire yeah amazing how
that can work right and it's not as hard
as one might think decision and that's
the hardest part we have as human beings
decisions are tough being something
different so like if you woke up
tomorrow let's change your hats you're
not you anymore you don't have the
wealth you have you don't have the
beautiful stuff you have in your life
and you got a nice job and you're doing
okay in the world or you want to get
ahead how comfortable would you be
changing your identity to the people
around you that you are actually working
on this and you meant it at the
beginning it's easy because either
they're going to listen to you or not
but are you willing to go through six
months to a year till everybody sees you
differently yeah within one year I
promise anybody that you really commit
to this people will start asking you
advice yeah and that's the real
ancillary benefit they'll ask you advice
then you become the expert so you talk
about influence one of the things that's
coming through to me in everything that
you've been describing and and I can see
the threads of influen in at all but uh
I guess the most important person
influence is to influence yourself and
that's really cuz it's one thing you
know my mother used to say to me growing
up uh when you talk to yourself watch
your language and that's good mom gets
credit for that one I I remember her
saying that to me as a kid if I'd say
something that was self-deprecating
whatever she say say me talk to yourself
about your language you're listening so
now you know wow yeah when I when I'm
looking at uh you know how you're
talking about communication and
influence through
communication uh but then I guess you
got to turn that into in the mirror also
I guess and say okay what because you're
talk about identity so you so how do you
influence yourself to create a new
identity or to move towards a new
identity okay so this is interesting
this is like high level but everybody
can handle this conversation we warn our
children about stranger danger and watch
out out people out on the street right
we don't warn our children about the
internet to the levels that we need to
that there's all kinds of stuff out
there that you got to be careful what
you look at cuz you can't UNL at that
right okay what you saw in our minds we
have the ability to we we everything we
have that's ever happened to us is SED
in picture sounds and feelings inside of
our brain everything the first time you
get into an accident or your first time
you're falling in love how you store
that and where you keep that in your
head is completely up to you but nobody
tells us that how much you make it
matter so your file for wealth is inside
of your brain but the question is is it
one that you got from someone else or is
it is it one that you want or what do
you want it to be so when it comes to
influencing yourself the big the big
question you have to ask yourself is
like are you going to accept that you're
controlling the communication inside of
your head are you one of these people
that says I can maybe sort of I don't
know how or are you making it necessary
for you to do so when I go back to the
word non-negotiable like are you really
working towards what it is that you want
and the pictures sounds and feelings do
you have inside of your head are they
aligned with what it is you're doing and
really taking a minute going wait a
second I got some stuff I need to clear
up like I need to think about this my
dad always told me wasn't good with
money or you always screw everything up
do you want that voice in your head you
don't have to have that voice in your
head you cannot have that voice in your
head if you want to be wealthy or allow
that voice to drive you yeah okay that's
the question so how much are you really
going to accept the power of your own
influence over yourself and once you
accept that power that's that's where
the creativity comes in so there isn't
an exact answer that I can figure out in
the next 15 seconds if you want to give
me a scenario I can I can probably give
you a solution for that but I believe
that it's your communication with you
that's going to make it the easiest so
now uh somebody's been watching this you
know and seeing the progression of these
thoughts and ideas Etc the conversation
ends yep and now they have to take a
step what's the step they should take
first step you're going to have to do is
decide um and not talk decide and a
decision is very different than talking
and I always say watch where people's
feet move because if you're bowling you
know the direction of their feet you can
always tell like and as a chiropractor
you can tell like what direction
people's have been walking based on
their shoulders and everything you bow
and your looking that way the balls
going that way so you're going to have
to move towards what it is you want I'd
recommend if you want to change your
relationship with money number one is
how much do you have how much do you
really want except the disparity between
those two and the difference between
them is you being a different person and
really accept I'm here and I want to be
here it is not about a location you're
going to wind up it's a state of being
yeah how do you become that person well
the first step in the right direction
like I tell anybody if you're not
willing to right now transfer $5
automatically a week a day a month a
year from one account to another and
take five minutes and do that Auto on
your thing I won't even give you lesson
two right lesson one is that you do
lesson one you let it sit there for a
week or two I'll give you lesson two
lesson two is we're going to change a
relationship with money we're going to
start figuring out what we're spending
what we're buying and where the money is
yeah and you're going to get it from
other people got it well I have to tell
you I feel like we could talk about this
for years years and uh I really
appreciate you sharing your own personal
Journey but then also kind of the wisdom
that that came from that that you can
share with the world but uh the mindset
of wealth is something that I think is
is really a um complex or can be a
complex comp but uh I think you just
simplified it a great deal so I
appreciate you sharing it all look at it
as a relationship and look at as one of
those things and start respecting money
and I think people have a lack of
respect for it start looking how you
spend it you'll see how much you respect
it you start respecting it it respects
you it's like a great relationship buy
it flowers sometimes take care of it pet
it this is this is cuz people say uh you
know the love of money is root of all
evil I said uh what do you mean by love
not lust but love to lick it you know
what I'm saying you have you just have
to have a relationship with it love is
you know love is is respect love is
buying it flowers love is you know you
know paying attention to visit it yeah
visit it spend some time with it figure
out what you have spend some time with
it and ask yourself like if your
relationship was a $100 and you wanted a
million-dollar relationship would you
just settle with your $100 sit down with
a beer and have a relationship with it
no you'd nurture it you'd figure it out
you'd bring it friends yeah You' You'
help it grow you'd help it do more just
changing your relationship with it is
read it a bedtime story read it a book
let it watch the video awesome Michael
has been really stimulating and
entertaining so me too thanks enjo yeah
thanks so much for doing this absolutely
honor and a privilege and love to help
out any way I
can we're so excited about the momentum
that's been building through the free
viewing period of wealth breakthroughs
and I want to say a special thank you
for those who purchased the series it
means the world to us it helps us get
this information out into the world so
people everywhere can have their wealth
breakthrough and it really is something
that is gratifying and sincerely I want
to be able to say thank you for
purchasing this series and I hope that
it changes your
[Music]
life hi welcome back next up we have
Aaron Kennard probably the most famous
passive income coach in America today
he's going to show you exactly I'm
talking step by step how to replace the
income you get from your job with income
that piles up while you sleep waren
Buffett said it best if you don't find a
way to make money in your sleep you'll
work until you die here's Aaron with the
whole
story Aaron very much looking forward to
this conversation about passive income
totally me too so so let's get to your
background first what did you do as far
as your career your business as an
entrepreneur or before even um I started
buying uh houses in 2006 why what got
you to start buying houses uh read a
book uh rent to some
seminars essentially it started in well
it started earlier started probably 2002
reading Rich Dad Poor Dad playing the
cash flow game with my friends and
family learning about cash flow really
and kind of feeling drawn
toward that seeing the appeal to that
from college at this point I was in I
had dropped out of college I was like uh
doing sales I ran a couple sales
organizations dor sales crews in various
States and U at the time so I was making
decent money doing that but had a was
just drawn toward real estate drawn
toward passive cash flow um from kind of
those sources uh that I mentioned and
then and then I ended up flipping one
house like did did a spec home and that
worked out well amidst where it
shouldn't have maybe were you following
what you learned in the books or were
you yeah I mean I was trying to apply
that stuff you know in the sense that oh
learning about passive cash flow and hey
let's go get an asset that throws off
cash flow well I kind of followed the
stuff but didn't really because I went
and flipped a house the first thing
which is not passive at all that's like
just generate a bunch of money you just
took the words out my mouth so when we
say passive cuz we I'm going to create
passive income I see them working their
their butts off I don't see anything
passive about it a lot of us get into
the mode of like and I did let me go
make some money I thought I had to go
make a bunch of money so that I could
then invest it MH uh to create passive
cash flow passive income right so that's
why I went and like flipped a house at
first and then it luckily it worked out
but when I in6 when I started doing like
real estate full-time it was because I
read a book that tipped me off to the
fact that I didn't need my own money and
that I could create and buy assets with
other people's money and I it was like a
revelation to me at the time I didn't
realize that I was good at sales but I I
realized oh I can just go raise capital
I can just go do that kind of sales and
so then I I quit my sales job at the
time I was kind of burned out on that
and I um just started buying house I
started raising capital and buying
houses in the Denver area and so how'd
you raise Capital just first person is I
called my dad MH I was just like hey you
have any money that's not earning 10 or
12% interest and he did and then I did a
deal I had a deal in mind I actually had
a deal under contract right went and
found a house to buy I looked at the
numbers did the and found out hey if I
can get this money I can flip it m and I
just called him and did a deal and uh so
what was the what was the deal though
there words okay so do you have money so
here's the pitch do you have money
that's making uh you know 10 to 12 or
less than 10 to 12% uh interest yeah and
if they said well uh actually I'm making
less than that what do you what have you
got what would you I just like well do
you want to make 12% secured by real
estate mhm I'm going to do a deal I'm
going to buy this house house you'll be
the lender you'll be like the first
position mortgage so if if the deal goes
bad or if I die or whatever you've got
the house as security collateral you're
going to make 10 I told it was 12% at
the time I said you're going to make 12%
interest I'm going to buy the house I'm
going to fix it up and then we're going
to sell it you're going to get all your
principal back plus your interest for
the time period and uh how' that deal
work out um that deal I mean all the
deals with the lenders I did worked out
good for them I over the course of time
I bought hundreds houses over the years
where some of them I lost money and some
of them I made money so I don't remember
that specific deal whether it worked out
good for me or not it worked out great
for him all all of my lenders always
made really good money so that was that
was good so then what happened so you
got that deal done work then what was
next so that turned into um wanting to
take over the world suddenly and like I
ended up getting a business partner
getting an office getting staff and just
going on a fundraising Rampage and I
bought like 30 houses that year and we
were going to buy and hold a bunch one
year 30 houses yeah wow okay yeah like
and and I was in charge of like raising
capital and finding the deals and I got
a partner who was kind of in charge of
managing it did you raise enough Capital
uh were you were you just using that
capital for down payments or were you
using that cap no I was Raising it for
everything like I would buy I would
borrow enough to buy the house and
renovate the house W and so I I learned
very quickly that like actually the
before I borrowed money from my dad the
very first deal I did I've used all my
own cash like I flipped that first house
and then I went and and did another one
all with cash like a $70,000 house and I
was all cash strapped and I decided from
that point on I was never going to use
my own money anymore because I hated
being cash strapped I hated being like
and so I just committed I was just using
other people's money so I just borrow
the whole purchase price the whole
repairs everything and then um fix it up
flip it or hold it depending on the
model so you got a partner you got
office space you you did 30 deals um so
you had booming business yeah except
that that was in 2008 the market crashed
everything started to go Haywire we and
also not only did the market crash but
we were um uh we I I it was foolish
business uh management really on my part
just we were basing out on the best case
scenario like oh we're going to make
$100,000 a month if we do this and this
well pretty quick we had an overhead of
50,000 a month and we weren't making
50,000 a month so I had this train wreck
kind of waiting to happen and the market
crashed which made it so that the houses
we bought were worth less and we were
going to have to like not make profit on
those so anyway it was I ended up having
to like exit The Business Partnership
pay off my partner uh fire everybody
move into my house and go on like a
rampage of buying and flipping houses
the next year my inial my initial model
was to buy and hold to build up passive
cash flow and during that through that
train wre I had to basically eject on
that model and just go full I went into
tons of debt to stop from paying to stop
from defaulting on all these loans loans
and I had to get personal I was taking
out like credit card debts to like
finish these deals because of the cash
flow crisis that I was in so now you so
yes you're negative equity at that point
I guess and you got with other people's
money yeah it was really stressful a
couple million dollars of other people's
money and scrambling to come up with
enough to do the rehabs to finish them
to get them sold and stuff like that but
now you get rid of your partner also so
you guys didn't do it together you just
uh basically had to split up the
relationship and you took the
responsibility I took everything yeah it
was it was more like I had to basically
pay him off and then um and then just
went like worked my butt off to like 2
in the morning so many days and and
buying and selling more houses to flip
and pay like to make cash were
transactions happening after right after
2000 well then this is when it got crazy
awesome so so it crashed and I had all
this overhead I needed to basically get
rid of that overhead and get rid of
those deals but also now it became Prime
buying time because because the prices
were plummeting right and we're in
Denver we're buying houses for 20 30
$40,000 for these houses and that were
just moments earlier selling for 70,000
right so but did you have the resources
or you know the the the money vehicles
to buy those houses yes I just went and
borrowed more money I just went and
raised more Capital so people yeah so
you're already at stressed with your
current well I was stressed my lenders
weren't stressed they weren't like I
wasn't defaulting on anybody I had just
built a cash flow issue and I was able
to weather that because I was able to
get enough debt personal debt to kind of
weather that storm and so I never would
defaulted on anybody so everybody
everybody's loved my deals let's let's
talk about the the psychology there
though because that's a that's kind of a
gutsy move you you you know you
basically you're sitting there saying
uhoh uh the momentum has gone completely
against me yeah I'm now you know and you
got to be strung out from not sleeping
you know from the sounds of it uh and
instead of just trying to find a way out
you double down you basically go out and
raise more money ch model like at the
time I was the model was flawed what I
was starting with was all Buy and Hold
those first 30 houses I was attempting
to buy and hold and create a cash flow
portfolio right but my interest rates
were too high I didn't have it was it
was kind of a flawed model the way I was
building it and so when I doubl down it
was I'm not buying and holding anymore
I'm flipping I'm flipping to make cash
to pay off this debt and so that model
was it was different and it was um there
was tons of flip deals available MH
right so I I was able to get lots of
deals renovate them flip them and
generate cash and you and you didn't
default in any of your obligations as
far as your loans yeah thankfully I feel
super fortunate it just it was super
stressful but then just putting in the
work to keep doing deals and generating
and and actually making profit in cash
flow I was able to kind of like ride
through that were you a single guy at
that time no I was married I had two
kids W I think I might have got an ulcer
at that time I don't know it was pretty
stressful I was going to say so uh and
you cuz that had to be very tough on the
relationship our third kid actually 2008
July wow and then it that was like a low
point in life for me cuz that was right
when everything was crashing and this
business was going haywire I was like 30
lbs overweight and um I remember a shift
like 2009 J January I just decided I'm
just like I'm taking care of
myself I had I had just so much stress
with all that I had made this decision
I'm going to work out first every single
day before anything else and and it kind
of shifted my whole ability I mean
that's kind of underlying my capacity to
actually do that was taking care of
myself physically spiritually first
because it put me in a mode of like of
mental strength right rather and so I I
had that every day i' just get up and
work out and then I was clear-headed and
then I was able to like take on the
challenge and feel good and confident
well so now this becomes sort of
interesting for you know the themes that
we're we're looking for right cuz that
sounds like an inflection point it was
you basically you you're in a a low
uhhuh three little kids relationship a
lot of debt yeah everything went against
you and what happens you you get up one
more decide I got to take care of myself
yeah um and by doing so that was the
would you say that was the foundation
that was definitely a foundation for
everything that came after that like if
I wouldn't have done that I wouldn't
have had the wherewithal to probably
weather that I mean I was just going
downhill I was gaining weight I was
stressed it was just a bad cycle right I
didn't and so then I had the it's like
doing that I then had the daily capacity
to to just think differently be more uh
be proactive and make better decisions
well let's talk yeah so because that's
really what it sounds like is that uh
you know it's it's the clarity of
thinking or that's required navigating
it's easy when you got momentum and
everything's great right and you know
that but really you're tested and and if
you want talk about you know
breakthroughs for wealth yeah uh you
know you're really tested Ed uh you know
from a psychological standpoint almost
more than anything else yeah cuz if I
were to look if I were to look at your
predicament right I whatever I see a guy
that's you know business is you know in
trouble the Market's against him he's
got a lot of debt he's stressed he's
gaining weight he's unhealthy um you
know I that's not a type of scenario I'd
want to put money into or invest in so
uh so you basically said you get down to
your own foundations first and then from
there when you can get clearheaded you
can make better decisions yeah and it's
interesting now that you're bringing
that up I remember now between uh
January and February 2009 was when I had
this huge breakthrough on Capital
raising I was still kind of stuck in
fact that is that is I'm I'm remembering
the story now I actually I had that
breakthrough personally which gave me
the confidence and at the time I had a
real estate coach but he had I was
struggling to get more Capital mhm be
and you can imagine why I mean I'm I'm
in everything you just explained right
my confidence was low not to mention
not a lot of people wanting to deploy
Capital right then yeah I mean it was it
was a crunch time right but it was in
February I remember now um I had this
breakthrough with my coach where he he
helped me kind of reframe some beliefs
around raising Capital where I had I had
these internal beliefs that I was
begging for money and that it was like
me taking their money or something and
he helped me reframe it like that I was
actually they needed me big time like
people are making 1% interest 2%
interest and here I am I have an
opportunity for them to make sec 10%
interest and I'm like I'm uh leaving my
friends and family out cold by not
offering that to them so he flipped the
script on me helped me realize the
actual reality of the situation is that
I had so much to give to people right
and it's and it's just a mutual awesome
relationship business relationship that
flipped the script and suddenly within
in February between February and like
March I raised like $2 million of
capital I had I remember I had this
Vision that I would write I had like
affirmations at the time like one of
them was I have 2 million of capital to
invest and by the end of March I had
that and like it was coming from maybe I
had a few hundred thousand or something
before that but that's what
springboarded my capacity to then buy
flip deals right I was I had $2 million
and I could go buy pay 100,000 or 70,000
to buy a house for 50 needed 30,000 in
renovation and so pretty quickly I had
20 houses in the in inventory that I was
um then flipping and then it was then it
became a management challenge to get
those things renovated and sold and
stuff but and especially it's seems like
you didn't have a whole lot of Staff
around yeah all I had was an I kept an
assistant I had kept an assistant but
then eventually like the next year I got
a project manager but that whole year
2009 I was running around like crazy and
I had contractors right that were
managing that so luckily I had some good
contractors in place that would get the
work done but I was trying to run around
to 20 properties and at a time all the
same time while buying new properties
and I think I bought and sold 54 houses
that year wow 2009 yeah so uh so what
emerged from there so you sounds like
you got turned around yeah so I made a
lot of cash that year it was a really
good year and it and then it led to
having a project manager for the next
year and um I kind of got in the mode of
flipping houses for the next few years
but it became this cycle like it's like
the very next year I remember looking at
these numbers I sold 54 houses in 2009
in 2010 I did that again MH except in
2009 we made a bunch of money and paid
off a bunch of debt 2010 the tax credit
the government was giving for first-time
home buyers ended and my contractor went
bankrupt on me and I had about 30 houses
in inventory at the time the end result
of that for that year was I lost like
$200,000 sold 54 houses in 2010 and lost
200,000 like I should have you should
net at least a million dollars 20,000
per house right like I ended up losing
like I wented to debt more in 2010 after
working the entire year flipping 54
houses why was that because I mismanaged
the whole thing I was I was not the best
man I'm good at raising capital and
doing deals management is not my forte
right it's not my and so I was like
bored of it my project manager obviously
did I didn't manage him tight enough I
allowed my contractor to like I I paid
my contractor tons of money because I
trusted him and then he didn't do the
work I wasn't checking in on the
properties I wasn't doing good I wasn't
being a really good Financial Steward as
it turns out a good manager of the money
right and so my contractor goes bankrupt
and I'm left with houses that haven't
been renovated but I've already spent
the budget and then the market tanks and
all the equity goes out so it just it
was a bad recipe it was a bad year so
just for you just when you thought
you're you're free and clear yeah then I
went further into debt wow and uh so how
did you turn that around the same way I
did the first time I went and did more
the next year I did it smarter I thought
and I did for 2011 and 12 then I was
making money again I didn't make those
same mistakes I managed it tighter MH
but it was like the cyclical thing of
churn making money and risk like some
deals I would make money some days I
would lose money and all of it was not
my original intent which was to create
wealth right to create passive cash flow
I'm now on this like rat wheel of like
flipping houses and flipping money and
some years losing money some years
making money and never feeling like I'm
getting closer to my actual goal so was
there another uh you know inflection
point or pivotal moment you know that
that said okay uh I'm I'm ready to do
this in a different way you know yeah
there's probably a lot
um the I mean in 2012 I kind of got
burned out of real estate because of
that and I actually started a whole
different business like I started
writing personal development books and
and which then turned my real estate
kind of into more passive I had my
project manager running most of it and
it kept going it became kind of like a
passive business for me and it still
went pretty well but had this Hiatus
where I was writing books and teaching
and had a whole another kind of course
of life but
meanwhile in
2015 I finally like said no I'm done
with the flipping business and that was
the real inflection point I think was
the flipping business uh I realized it's
so risky 2015 I was about I was losing
money again finally I said I'm stopping
this because I realized that I actually
over the course of time from 2006 to now
it's
2015 I had been forced almost to keep
some of these properties and I had built
up a portfolio of about 30 rental
properties all of which were just kind
of maintaining mhm but in 2015 I I went
and looked at the numbers and I like
refinanced some of them restructured
raised some rents and all of a sudden I
realized I had enough cash flow to live
on mhm it had just like built up in the
background is this your what well is
this your definition of um passive
income or you how do you define passive
income yeah I mean I would say passive
income is income coming in without you
having to do work on it would you
characterize that as passive income that
that was not completely because I was
managing some of it right I mean I guess
some people would cify that as passive
income but if you're sitting there doing
the property management that's work
right if if you've got a house or you've
got properties that are completely
managed out by somebody else I consider
that passive income because I'm not
doing any day-to-day on anything it's
just the money's coming in and I man I'm
managing that but you're not completely
ignoring it either right I mean you have
to pay attention well but yeah I guess
there's different levels passivity if
you if you will but that's pretty
passive when you have for the most part
by 2015 I'd got most of my properties
managed out by a partner or a manager
and so it was just passive all I was
doing was looking at the numbers coming
in every month and answering his
questions if he had any you know on the
bookkeeping or whatever and so now if we
carry that forward to where we are now
yeah uh because you know I understand
you know you're around a group of
entrepreneurs at a mastermind and
they're talking about different things
and suddenly you start talking about how
you're supported through you know
completely supported through passive
income yeah and they start to lean in
and say well tell me more about that so
what is it like now for you you know
what is your means of passive income and
what's your life like so it's
essentially since 2015 I got to the
point of having enough like my my house
portfolio was like more than my expenses
to live on like my passive income after
management and then in the last 4 years
uh I've just parlayed that into bigger
deals and greater passive cash flow so
it's like been selling houses when I
have opportunities moving it into Mobile
Home Park opportunities with other
partners moving it into bigger deals
that are all passive like for me um
sometimes raising capital and putting
that I mean I mean in a partnership with
him doing that so now as a picture of
today now I own I still own houses that
throw off passive cash flow but now I
own part like part ownership in lots of
different mobile home parks that are
throwing off even more passive cash flow
with greater tax benefits and so my my
cash flow has grown over the last four
years although I haven't had an active
income per se it's just been like moving
kind of moving Capital around but you're
and I guess this I guess this is the
thing is that uh you're still got pretty
good amount of business activities to go
create you know all that right as far as
you the deals examining them you know
the part you know not really making it
tell me then yeah cuz it's not sounding
that passive to me so like no like when
I like really it was just just for
example my buddy came to me with it with
the opportunity to get into mobile home
parks and he's and so I had to just do
my due diligence on that deal which was
upfront was maybe a couple of weeks of
not full-time but just looking into it
and then it was investing my money mhm
and that's it and then now for the last
3 years that's just money coming in
every quarter I don't do anything I just
get reports right so it wasn't it wasn't
a lot and and then like the next year
the work was oh tell my agent to sell
these houses right so we sell the houses
and I have my property manager my
contractor just go and make sure the
stuff's ready to sell money comes in and
then I reinvest that into this other
deal I actually haven't done tons of
lots it's not like I've been spending
time doing deals during all this time
that's happening from 2016 to 2019 I was
actually doing a completely other
business I started a software startup so
the the the passive income was all like
really pretty passive there's stuff to
do here and there sure like but it none
of the day-to-day and and as soon as the
investment was made it's all just like I
have an there's an operating company my
partner in his company that runs the
whole thing and it just distributes the
checks so that that actually put me into
position to be able to go invest and I
co-founded and co-funded a software
startup
which just didn't work Out 3 years later
couple hundred, and um I ended up
quitting walking away because I realized
this it wasn't working out and so that
that was a whole another thing were you
able to support those losses through
your passive income yeah and I knew that
going in yeah like I had I had that
money up front M meaning I I had the
couple hundred, and going into that
business I said this is what I'm willing
to lose 200,000 I knew going into just a
super risky deal I mean creating a
software startup is just risky there's
nothing like really estate it's like
super risky potentially huge returns
right but really risky and I knew going
in that um that I could lose it all and
I was willing to do that it was a small
percentage of our net worth it wasn't it
wasn't like I was putting all our chips
in that basket it was it was um
something that I was passionate about
for various reasons doing and it felt
good about it and anyway at the end
three years later I finally said I'm
done and uh I was glad that I didn't go
over ex I mean it was just kind of the
my plan to be willing to lose that much
from the get-go and we lost it I didn't
like it it was a huge gut punch I hated
it actually but it was it was it didn't
our net worth continued to rise the
whole time like you're able to manage
through that yeah our cash flow kept
going up our net worth went up it was
not a it didn't stop anything and that's
a Hu I guess you ask what's the picture
like today like uh because I have assets
that throw off cash flow that are
growing up in value you know I have the
freedom to do something like that
without stress at that software startup
wasn't actually really stressful for me
right like it could be highly stressful
if you're trying to make money and you
don't know where the next meal is going
to come from man I could only see the
ulcers that that would cause from
somebody who's starting out in software
I was not stressed in any way during
those three years I was Backcountry
skiing like three times a week four
times Well five times a week sometimes
to the Chagrin of my wife but like but
anyway I had a pretty free lifestyle
even doing that software startup because
of having assets that the Peace of Mind
the security the stability of kn knowing
like my my net worth is rising my cash
flow is good yeah I'm investing this it
was an investment at that point of my
time and my money but it wasn't a
stressful it wasn't stressful in the way
that I was like worried about our money
and our finances you know so let me ask
you where you are right now yeah is
there if the real estate market were to
go down does that matter or not really
matter because you're you're renting
these properties they're producing cash
flow it mostly matters if you're trying
to sell right if you're if you're going
to hold for the long term and it's cash
flowing uh then the only effect of it
going down is okay do the rents go down
mhm are the rents going to go down on
the most affordable housing in the
country demand probably goes up if
anything it probably goes up because you
have foreclosures or whatever happen so
that's why that's specifically why I
moved from houses I had I had like some
of my houses had gone up five or six
times in value or seven times W from
when I was buying them at 24,000 right
and then so I'm selling and taking the
equity off the table of these houses
that are in a more volatile state moving
it into a more stable place that cash is
greater that that was my intent that was
why I moved into into mobile home parks
and different things like that so it's a
it's a more stable thing coming up
against the recession well because you
you know from your first story you know
on the 2008 crash basically uh you're
now got some years of experience and
wisdom behind you so how are you
prepared now uh for another crash or
another you know correction if it comes
well it's you know keeping more cash
reserves in the bank mhm so that it's
having assets that are throwing off cash
flow that can support us that are in
that are uh more recession resistant M
right that are in a stable place in the
face of whatever coming recession might
happen that's basically it I mean I just
from the from the passive cash flow
standpoint and then also from you know
maybe a mental and like
a it in the event of a crash I want like
I'm in a better cash position to take
advantage of that cash position and also
um just networked position to go and and
do deals with people and understand and
have capacity to then take advantage of
a crash right and that's what I was
going to ask you is is saying that uh
you know if you have cash in reserve uh
when something goes wrong like that you
can go bargain hunting right yeah it's
just the best I mean yeah you want
definitely want to have cash I mean it's
like Warren Buffett when the 2008
happened he just like doubled his net
worth or something over the course of
two years because he had all this cash
right and he just bought everything for
pennies on the dollar Ted Turner right
uh you know became a huge landowner
because his his whole thing was staying
cash until something happens and then
you know the because most people are
sitting there in a compromised position
like you were in the last crash and then
the people with cash can come in and
make really great deals yeah yeah if you
compare where I was in 2008 like I still
I didn't sit on the sidelines I actually
took advantage of that crash even though
I didn't have any personal money you
were able to raise it but I did it I
wish I would have done differently and
if I do it in the future I'll do it
differently I'll take advantage of
Building Wealth because I I kept about
30 houses in that process I could have
kept 200 houses and that would have been
a much different wealth story right if
you're if you have 200 houses that go up
5x right as opposed to 30 so it's um
next time around I will definitely do it
with like a more of a wealth building
long-term cash flow I won't be so
strapped for cash personally that I will
need to like get into flipping and
churning so uh at this point for
yourself so it sounds like your your
comfortable living expenses are all
covered yeah through the passive income
that you're generating do you still have
uh ambition to go build to grow grow
more or are you kind of like saying hey
I enjoy my Backcountry skiing and my
life with my my family so what's your
plan yeah my plan is to grow and to
serve and to give right like I I went
through this mode of actually I went
through a really stagnated mode these
last three years when I buildt that
software company I was I was I was
engaged it was really with the F with
the the desire to really serve people
right and to create something that was a
value and it didn't work it didn't do
anybody any good and so in the last six
months I've been in a huge Funk uh from
just not contributing and it's not a
good place to be and when I when I was
skiing like six days a week I everybody
would be saying oh man you live a truly
amazing life in fact that's the name of
my other brand is truly amazing life.com
or whatever like like that and and they
would tell me that and at the time I was
like I I was actually more depressed or
more down than I'd been in a long long
time I'd be skiing like six days a week
and that part was fulfilling but it was
like way out of balance I wasn't
contributing I wasn't growing I wasn't I
mean I was just skiing a lot and it was
not fulfilling in that it wasn't that's
a really important piece of life right
like getting adventure and fun is great
and fitness but it's like if it's your
whole life then it's not a good way to
live it's not bad I don't like it any I
didn't feel good I wasn't as happy so my
plan I guess to your question going
forth is uh is to be more balanced but
to grow for sure like I I'm like really
really excited right now just even in
the last few weeks having just kind of
had some mental breakthroughs with with
some friends that have kind of tip
helped me kind of realize more that I
have a lot to contribute a lot to give
and there's a lot of people that could
really benefit from my advice coaching
and stuff which is which is why it's
I've become I kind of turned myself into
a passive income coach over the last
couple of months and that's
um it's just
like it's less about the money growth
it's more about the the contribution
right well this is where it gets
fascinating now because it it it almost
is like a paradox um where what's the
whole point of creating passive income
the whole point of creating passive
income is so I can go skiing six days a
week right well it might but but know
and it might be but no this is very
interesting because if if we look at the
trajectory of your experience you uh had
a uh yeah when when you were literally
in survival mode yeah uh it was like Hey
you know you weren't thinking about
contributing everything else at least
probably not so much much I trying to
survive you're just trying to survive
and keep your nostrils above water yeah
and I wasn't thinking about Backcountry
skiing or anything no no you and you
couldn't you know so uh so you said boy
I would love to be in a position where I
could go skiing six days a week but
what's interesting is that you get past
that whole survival level of of
existence and and the responsibility of
of uh you know honoring your obligations
from people who trusted you when they
invested in you yeah you get through
that whole Arc you get to a point where
now you don't really have to work your
your uh your family's taken care of yeah
and you have all the latitude to go
skiing as much as you want to and what
happens you don't find yourself
fulfilled yeah no seriously I became in
this mode of just I was feeling
depressed and like um so what's wealth
to you then you know that's an
interesting that's a really interesting
question what's wealth mhm it's it's
balance right for me for me it's Freedom
it's Financial Freedom but it's also
spiritual it's contribution it's love I
think at the core for me it's love mhm
like living in a state of Love is the
ultimate wealth and financially a lot of
people are blocked
uh from living in love because they're
living in survival mode or they're
stressed and so fin money is a really
fascinating thing to me now and how
always has been I've always loved been
intrigued by the topic of money but
there's so much like internal stuff
going on around money and I feel like I
have a lot to contribute on that uh to
people because yeah because I know I
started talking about other things you
ask what is wealth and answer your
question or does that yeah I mean I'm
trying to understand because people say
well I want to be wealthy so yeah you
know I'm what I'm hearing is you you
achieve that from the monetary
standpoint you know if you look at your
balance sheet and say Hey you own a lot
of assets uh you've got a cash flow that
uh doesn't require really much attention
from you yeah uh maybe that's a lot of
people's definition of wealth but if if
you're saying that um I've got that but
I'm depressed yeah um maybe uh you
reconsider what wealth really means yeah
I mean and it wasn't like I was always
depressed and I couldn't I might be
using that word like ially depressed
but I understand what you meant you just
you just weren't happy yeah I wasn't
yeah but at the same time I was grateful
super grateful for that wealth for that
mon monetary wealth right for the
passive cash flow it wasn't like I
wanted to get rid of it and I was super
grateful for the Financial Security
because a lot of things about it were
peaceful right there was a lot of peace
and Security in that of which I was
super grateful but I was missing the
contribution I was missing love I was
just missing a piece so I guess the
point that I take from that the point
that I see from that from my own life
is we and I have and you it's it's easy
to get uh the goal being P passive cash
flow right and that's not really the end
goal that's just one piece of life
that's valuable and this is what the
interesting thing is I mean for most
people especially most entrepreneurs uh
you know the the Holy Grail is saying I
get to a point where I've got income
generated I'm highly leveraged I have
very little work activity to do
everything is basically by my own choice
yeah and I'm living the life and the
lifestyle and have the security Etc and
say okay I made it you to whatever that
it is that destination yeah and uh and
what's fascinating is you can get there
and decide hm this isn't it yeah so
here's a thought experiment question if
something came along now said wow this
is a high contribution thing uhuh
something that would like you know if
this really worked and maybe the
software was kind of like that to a
degree but but it was measured but if if
you would you be willing at this point
if something came along that really
aligned with you spiritually as far as
what you want to do in the world how you
want to contribute and uh it put at risk
your uh your security uh and your your
being supported through a passive income
would you take that risk okay no not for
my no because it's it's
like i' would be neglecting my family i'
be neglecting my duty to take care of
the people that I'm in charge of right
to put at risk our financial livelihood
to go contribute in a bigger way no I
don't think so I mean I can contribute
without putting that at risk and if that
came along and if it was like Hey a huge
risk to like help a bunch of people at
the expense of maybe stressing my family
out or like no I'm going to take care of
my family I'm going to make sure they're
protected and I don't think that I need
to make that Jud and the psychologist is
very interesting because because many
entrepreneurs and and uh myself included
uh at times uh will push in their chips
you know they get passionate about
something and they'll push their chips
in yeah they'll put it all in yeah and
or they put a good chunk of it in that
that's not saying hey it's going it's
make or break but it's like if this
doesn't work rather than saying oh that
sucked but you know it doesn't really
matter uh it's it's crippling it sets
you back and and suddenly you you don't
have the freedoms that you had from a
financial standpoint anymore and so it's
interesting because here's what I'm
hearing is if you look at your values
uhuh right you're saying you know uh
getting to the point of being having
passive income and being fully supported
from that is my value above a potential
Venture that I have passion around that
is risky or could threaten that yeah
yeah and and and the other side the Risk
Takers say h you know what I value I
value taking that risk more than I value
having my security right now it's
interesting psychology when it comes to
wealth yeah and I wonder if most people
even thinking through that though I mean
I don't know it's like in hindsight I
have to say maybe I properly wasn't
thinking too clearly when I look at it
for myself so uh but uh and as you said
you know there are things along the way
that you kind of said wow if I look back
on it I wasn't really managing well I
wasn't doing this very well when I was
doing the real estate company my value
it was called our company was called E3
Spectrum Empower enable something inrich
right our value was to enrich our
investors and to empower our people it
was like very much value driven
and it failed and crashed and burned in
my face and uh I mean to that extent and
it put my family in stress it put me
made me not a good dad as good of a dad
as I could have been as good of a
husband made me unhealthy so having
viscerally gone through all of that like
I think that leads to why later like
when I did the software company that's a
hugely risky thing more risky than doing
real estate right but I contained that
so that it's not going to make me a like
not capable of doing my highest Duty
which is my highest value which is to my
family that's number one for me so I
think it was probably just because of my
past experience that I like I screwed it
up the first time right um I went I did
go all in I was too risky probably that
first time and I I didn't do it as
measured as I could of and I probably do
better now hopefully so now maybe based
on that imagine I'm a somewhat star eyed
young entrepreneur or maybe even
somebody who's been out there for a bit
and I come to you and I say okay what's
the best advice I want to I want to
create a passive income and and and
create that lifestyle that you're
describing what are the you know two or
three best pieces of advice you can give
me man that's hard because you're
talking there's a lot of variables about
this person who's coming to me so I
guess you're saying it's somebody who
doesn't have any net worth yet just
starting out i' say that they're either
from just starting out to maybe they've
gotten a little bit down the road or
they're making a living and they can
make decent money and they're ambitious
and they they can make some decent money
but they don't have a lot of excess cash
flow let's say I'm making $70,000 a year
and it cost me almost that much to live
but I I want to I want to work my way to
where you're going and then we'll take
it a different scenario gotcha first
it's under it's getting Clarity I think
on on how much you're spending how much
you're it's getting Financial Clarity uh
and and capacity to live within your
means M like that's number one it sounds
like that person maybe they don't have a
lot of savings maybe they don't have a
big security blanket 6 months like
there's certain fundamental financial
principles of security and peace that I
would say are like step one but it's
it's almost like have have a plan MH get
that person needs to have a plan of
what's the goal MH okay the goal is to
have $100,000 a year of passive cash
flow right to get to a point where I
have enough cash flow to live off right
okay the plan it starts with baby steps
of like I think getting Clarity on where
you are how much you spend and how much
you you earn so that you aren't
overspending first of all first and
foremost because then you can create all
the passive income in the world and
you're not good at managing it then then
you'll just spend 120 and make 100
100,000 and you'll be back you'll be in
the same boat right so anyway
fundamental financial principles getting
that clear what would be next look for
your first deal would you advise now buy
and rent not buy and flip get the
mindset around assets and cash flow so
that can be a lot of different things
right but it's the right mindset because
if you go into buying a house with the
wrong mindset or and you don't have
enough security blanket that can be
really stressful you could lose the
house there's all sorts of variables
that can go wrong right so I think the
principles would be understand you've
got to live within your means
M then understand that you want to own
assets that throw off cash flow that go
up in value like that should be the goal
from a Financial Security standpoint
most people that I most like if you go
on the internet and you go to like peral
management.com or all any of these sites
that like tell you how to manage your
net worth and grow that all of them are
like okay hire this financial adviser oh
and we'll tell you exactly what to do
and we will put all your money into
these stocks and these different things
we'll take a percentage per year and
we'll we'll manage your assets we'll
grow your wealth This Is wealth I'm kind
of anti all that like not that I think
that's 100% I just think that it's
fundamentally flawed MH like in my
opinion cash flow is so much more
important cash flow and assets are so
much more valuable so much more
appealing so much more like just so much
better than the financial Market people
do generally have done well over the
last 10 years in the financial markets
because the markets are booming well
then they're going to tank and people
will have their but it's not they're not
producing cash flow right like it's like
when you when you have the mindset of
I'm going to acquire assets that throw
off cash flow and it's it's Financial
Freedom it's independent of like some
advisor somewhere it's independent of
the dollar crashing it's independent of
like so what happens if the dollar
crashes and all those people who have
their wealth managers are making 1% per
year and it's all in stocks and the
market goes crazy and the businesses are
going out of business they lose 50% of
that well that's not very stable that's
seems pretty risky to me not to mention
you're not there's really no cash flow
stocks they're paying dividends but it's
not going to be everybody's doing this
for some long term I'm going to get
there sometime later so that's why I say
the the the mindset should be around
like now think about creating cash flow
what is your what are your expenses
every year or month however you want to
look at it if you're if you're making
$7,000 a year if you're if you're
spending 7 $70,000 a year to live on
you're making 6,000 a month okay start
your mindset should be how can I own
assets that produce cash flow that makes
6,000 a month mhm and start with 100 a
month go to 200 a month get it to 300
month start building and the key being
getting an asset something that's there
that's throwing cash flow there right
and put your effort toward that now the
tactics of what that could be well a
simple way is a house right you could go
and buy a house you can get a loan you
can put a down payment or you can do
like I did and you just go get other
people to give you the money like I've
bought hundreds of houses and dozens of
them I've bought with like all of I
don't buy any money down you can go get
money from other people you can find a
deal put together deal that then puts
$300 or $400 a month in your bank
account every month and has an asset
that's growing up in value building your
net worth so like houses is probably the
easiest from a person at that level
starting out houses or condos lower cost
real estate it's probably the easiest
most it's the simplest way to get in the
game I think that's how I got in how
tons of people get in the game and that
it's simple and you're getting cash flow
it makes sense now all of a sudden you
got $500 a month coming in well now you
only need 5,500 more just do that once a
year and 10 years later and plus those
houses are going up over time now it may
not be passive right so I say that but
like okay you might be doing work on
those it may not be passive initially
who cares like you're building the
potential for Passive cash flow so put
the effort in up front if the cash flow
is not that big you don't need to be
doing nothing right now the goal is to
yeah build up a passive cash flow stream
but that doesn't mean you can't work to
get it there right like and mine weren't
passive originally but then later on I
had the ability to have them all managed
out and now I've got assets it's all
passive right it built up over time and
so do the work to build up the passive
it doesn't have to be passive from the
get-go right but but then when when
you're at a higher net worth and you
have more income you can just put your
money into passive stuff from the get-go
that's like when I moved my money I
soell some houses I put it into a mobile
home park fund with my partner I didn't
do anything else and it's instantly
throwing off tons of cash flow giving me
other tax benefits so that's I guess why
the qualification um higher net worth or
higher income people I should say higher
income because I tend to I'm kind of put
myself in this position to help higher
income people there are a lot of higher
income people that are not high net
worth people because they just keep
spending as much as they are earning and
they're not putting into assets right
they're throwing off cash flow anyway
I'm I'm just a as you can tell like it's
all about cash flow for me like I don't
that's why I'm not into like stocks are
fine I guess in a percentage but you
read you I just read an article the
other day
this like it's
like 5% of your net worth maybe should
be in real estate the other 95% should
be in like stop mutual funds that was
literally the article and I was just
like are you kidding me like that's
flipflop for me maybe I'll put 10% in
mutual funds I don't have anything in
mutual funds I just don't even care to
have them in mutual funds I might invest
in this in index funds or index funds
but really I just like real estate
better and I have Diversified in various
real estate right so like why do I need
to why do I need to go in the stock
market for it's not it's not a
requirement most people just and I'm not
saying it's bad I've probably could make
tons of money in the stock tons of
people it's just not my expertise but I
don't like it because it doesn't produce
cash flow right in general it's a couple
times now you mentioned mobile home
parks yeah uh you seem somewhat excited
or enthusiastic about for sure yeah so
why well and I call them mobile home
parks they're actually manufactured home
communities is the technical term
because they're not even mobile right
like they're not it's just what we know
them as I guess as mobile home parks but
I'm I like that asset class for various
reasons but the cash flow is fantastic
there's enormous tax benefits for being
in that and also it's recession
recession resistant in my opinion I just
see it as I feel comfortable confident
and the results from the last two
decades have shown that when every other
asset class gets hit with volatility and
like apartment buildings or commercial
have all taken dips in in these
recessions mobile home parks have
basically straight lined up and it makes
sense because they it's the most
affordable housing and everybody needs a
place to live people are getting
foreclosed upon well they're losing
their house they got to live somewhere
right I mean it's just it makes sense on
a lot of reasons and are these rentals
Yeah Yeah so basically uh you you own
the well I own the land generally and
the people own their house on the
usually the people own their own mobile
their own manufactured home okay so they
bring that in and then they're paying
rent for or it's just there and they
bought it from somebody sometimes we own
the actual house as well and then we
have income on the land and income on
the house right but I I also like it uh
it's really a good Financial it's
financially really fantastic but I also
feel like it's it's socially really
great because it's uh it's pres there's
an affordable housing crisis and it's
preserving these um communities from
getting developed out like as an
investor as an owner as we're building
them and devel veloping them and getting
and improving them it's stopping them
from being developed into luxury condos
which there's a huge divide happening
right now in real estate and housing in
general where affordable housing it's
really a crisis right now and so it's
cool to be part of preserving what we
can in that I think is there a
particular part of the country that you
uh invest in these we are mostly in the
middle of the country like where I'm at
is mostly the middle of the country um
for Bigs that's where we've been able to
get the the right kind of deals but
they're all over uh I mean I know people
that are all over and I might be
invested all over because I'm looking
into other um other groups to invest
with as well so it's not like it's
limited to one spot in the twist and
turns that these interviews often take
you've got me fascinated by this uh
mobile home park investment uhhuh there
uh was a a late night talk show host who
started ripping into people who invested
in it was pretty funny actually but it
was also disheartening I mean it was
like from somebody in that space he
classified everybody as kind of villains
who were who were doing who were owning
mobile home parks and investing in that
space because you can compromise people
right because so if if we understand
this if I understand this correctly
basically you're saying we own the dirt
uhhuh there's
people most of the time they own the
home sitting on the dirt most of the
time yeah sometimes we own the home as
well and we're renting that pure it's a
pure but in this case you're saying hey
I've got the land they need to park
their home or you know on a place on a
plot of land they own that these are
typically going to be very low-income
people well it's the most affordable
housing yeah so so it's so we're
starting you know with people that don't
have probably hardly any discretionary
income whatsoever and but their rents
their total rent is like less than an
apartment you know a few hundreds of
dollars less even after they own get the
financing on their home Etc right but if
they want to move on average what would
it cost to move one of those homes to a
new park yeah so it's probably 5 to
10,000 bucks which they don't have which
most of them probably don't have and so
you have a really low turnover rate as a
result like but it's also that's part of
why there's not turnover part of it's
because these parts usually have a
community feel like people stay there
for a long long time but part of that is
a huge part of that is probably because
it would cost a lot to move their thing
they could sell the they could sell the
home to somebody right it's not like
they're limited to just moving it they
could move somewhere and sell the home
right but if the rental on the dirt to
keep their home there goes up it's not
an attractive sale either yeah maybe not
right and the person in the park is
respon has the control the owner of the
park can raise the rent whenever it's
like month-to month rents usually say so
it's not like a lease that's got you
know basically saying it can't go up by
more than 5% a year B it's they're there
month-to month y the owner of the park
is in your case you're collecting month
to month so a real uh I guess I could
say immoral mercenary can go in there
and say let's lure all these people in
on a low rent you know and they they
budgeted themselves based on that and
once we got them we can just keep
raising it let's keep raising and that's
what he kind of like that talk show host
did was expose like some big corpor I
mean lots of uh big corporations are
buying these things and then just kind
of like raising the rents and and it's
really there's no competition because
you can't build new mobile home parks so
it's not like people even if they wanted
to move it's not like there's lots of
other space
to move their their manufactured home to
right it's not like there's new parks
going up all over the place and so it's
kind of a contained and actually a
dwindling Supply so it's really
favorable to the person owning it right
and they're they're in a lot of control
um which is it's fantastic investment
right but you could also you also have
people that don't have the best morals I
think and ethics that can take advantage
of people at that space like on the flip
side of that what we're doing is
preserving uh the the people that I work
with the Partnerships that I'm in in in
mobile home park space are specifically
intentioned to preserve uh affordable
housing right and so yeah we go in and
we optimize when we buy them we're
optimizing we're going and putting in
capital repairs to the place we're
making them better we we're fixing the
roads and just improving upon the place
and then sometimes we'll need to raise
the rents but it's not like we just
double the rents overnight and so it's
being conscientious of those people and
still trying to preserve the affordable
housing space while also making a good
business model and it can be it could be
a challenging balance right it's not
like and it could I can see where their
Temptation would be for big corporations
and people just to go in and take
advantage of that and raise it so much
and just try to squeeze every squeeze
everything out it's sad how many how
many uh manufactured homes would be in a
typical Park well they range from 20 a
small Park of like 20 to big parks of
500 wow well so uh or more
they can really vary and I guess
especially you know when you start
saying 500 or thousand there's a real
Community there a lot of big Community
yeah that's a huge Community right 500
homes it's it's pretty big yeah yeah
well Erin you got quite a story and uh
pretty amazing perspective you seem very
laid-back and relaxed about all this
stuff I guess so so maybe that's a part
of what it means to uh have passive
income that support your your lifestyle
and gives you that security uh so uh
final thought for anybody out there who
says you know I want to achieve this I
guess just to say that you can for sure
it's totally achievable uh
it's it's I think it's really get your
mindset wrapped around assets and cash
flow and maybe I'm plugging like the
Rich Dad thing but like his whole game
cash flow it's like I just started
playing that with my kids I'm not
plugging cuz I have any interest in that
but I started playing with my kids again
and it was enlightening to see that uh
those principles are really valid and
and I realized I used to play that game
with my brothers and sisters like 20
years ago and that informed kind of my
direction to great benefit right so I'm
grateful for that really grateful for
that teachings I learned from him and
and I would just pass that along that
like really get your get your head into
cash flow and get out of like the save
for later right start getting cash now
start taking control now and I think
that's the and doing the things and
realize that you can do that now you
don't have to wait for there's lots of
creative ways to think about creating
cash flow now even if you don't have
money and that's the other final thought
I would say so many people are like I
got to save up and I got to get well no
you you can literally there's lots of
people with money who aren't making any
interest on it and you know tons of them
they're your family and friends and you
can be like guess what I'm going to go
buy a house let's split the deal let's
both own assets with cash flow like
there's things people can do without
having to save for years because you can
just work with people who've already
saved for years yeah so final thoughts I
think that's great eron so listen really
informative and I really appreciate you
sharing all that with us yeah my
[Music]
pleasure finally today we have Jason
katsen back and Michael McClary from
amazing.com they're going to show you
how you can create your first product to
sell on Amazon without needing your own
manufacturer with very little startup
capital I mean a 24-year-old made
$100,000 per month using this strategy
the bottom line is to become truly Rich
you need to work for yourself not
someone else here's Jason and Michael to
show you
how Jason Mike thanks for taking time to
sit with us and have this conversation
so the joke is almost too easy and it's
probably not even funny to you anymore
but you have an amazing story right so
let's talk about uh you know your lives
maybe before amazing.com and then we'll
get into what you're doing right now so
Jason why don't you start tell us your
background yeah so originally I was um
going the corporate route with life but
I uh back in 2003 I remember the CEO
decided to abolish all bonuses that year
and I just realized that I needed to
stop working my butt off to line other
people's uh pockets and it needed to be
more about what I could spend my time on
to give me the most Roi so I started my
first business back in 2005 and it was
uh a pretty cool success you know that
first year we did over $3
million um and it just really got me the
bug for the internet I went from you
know working for a corporate company
where I was working all these hours to
try to improve my lifestyle and I found
I just had to work more and more hours
and it didn't seem like I had any
freedom and then I started my own
business and all a sudden I could work
work from home I could travel as long as
I had an internet connection it was good
now back then Wi-Fi wasn't like it was
now so the freedom wasn't quite the same
um was it a related industry uh or was
it well what I did initially was I I
started with little ebooks so um I would
research topics online and I would
figure out what people were looking for
whether it was learning to get your
driver's license health issues and then
I would hire ghost writers to write the
content and then I would use SEO lot of
article creation article marketing to um
to just dominate the search engines and
I started doing really really well so
then I started teaching that and I
launched a product in 2005 called portal
feeder that was based off of that how to
build websites to be able to promote
affiliate programs products anything
like that and that's when I realized the
feedback I got that I was very good at
teaching um because I was very um I had
a lot of empathy with the people I would
really work hard with them I cared a lot
about customer support and we got a lot
of feedback on that early that um it was
our customer support that made the
difference because we really followed
through with the customers and so I
started refining that membership model
and teaching model and it was always
based on the businesses I was doing it's
like I had to be a success in the
business I was teaching and so initially
starting back in 2005 it was focused on
SEO and PPC but all Google related and
then in 2012 not 2012 2010 that's when
all the penguin and all those things
came out from Google with the different
algorithm changes and I realized I was
kind of doing the same thing again I was
working for someone else I wasn't
creating an asset because I was building
businesses always based on hacks and you
know how you can trick the search
engines rank on the search engines but
then suddenly the search engines decide
to change their algorithm it's like
you're you're you have to start over and
that's when I met Matt Clark actually it
was in um I'm not sure if you've heard
of the Mavericks um it's a mastermind
group yanic silver yeah yeah yeah and so
we met in that I joined that in
201 and me and Matt got into a
mastermind group and so he was here's
this young 24 year old kid at the time
doing like $100,000 a month selling his
own product on Amazon it was just
mind-boggling to me it's like how can
you have your own manufacturing and he's
like well I private label it and I knew
private label from the context of
content you know like for someone to you
know to repurpose content but he was
actually doing it with product so he
started teaching me that and so when I
launched my first product within four
months I was doing over $100,000 a month
profit wow um and that was because I was
able to take all my SEO skills all my
marketing skills from Google and
translate it onto Amazon now I also had
a little bit of a helping hand because
at that time Dr Oz was really pushing uh
Health supplements like C uh garcini
Cambogia raspberry ketones and my first
product was a raspberry ketone um and so
that really helped but
the cool thing was is the product I
started selling was the exact product
that my manufacturer was selling but
because I differentiated it used all my
marketing skills I was selling my
product for three times as much as my
manufacturer and I was made I was ranked
number one and they were like number 30
kind of thing so it was uh so the bug
hit um and we started teaching people
the Amazon model I ask a question about
that I'm really curious so your manufact
so basically you you were being you were
white labeling from your manufacturer
mhm and uh when you started
outperforming them on such a significant
basis did they at least like take notice
and say hey maybe we should copy some of
what you're doing or were there any
conversations around that no interesting
enough as much as I thought that it
would actually hurt me once they figured
out who I was the opposite because
manufacturers most of them that's their
business model is the manufacturing side
they're not marketers um and so they
almost just dabble in that kind of stuff
but you know a lot of lot of our
students have asked that like what about
when the manufacturer finds out that
you're selling the product like well
that's not their business model it's
like my business model isn't
manufacturing now sometimes sellers will
start to develop so much they build
their own facility to manufacture I
don't want to get into that I don't want
to have more warehouses and employees
and those kind of things so no um and in
fact they uh they it was more of a
partnership they started giving me
better deals because um I was such a
high-profile seller and they kept
dropping the price on me so it was just
the only problem was the one drawback of
that industry is I didn't like selling
that product um you know and that's
something with any business like I think
you know it's great to start a testing
business like when you're going into
business you always you know like don't
look at it like I'm going all in on this
like you know test the waters make sure
and that's what we tell a lot of our
students is you know pick a product and
learn the business model learn the
system and then start building a real
business did you think there was gravity
there and there so you said Dr Oz was
promoting this so was that what got your
attention said hm I think I can it was
research it was really it was just
following our strategies of figuring out
what are the best sellers on Amazon how
many reviews do they have how much
competition does it look like they have
is this an Emerging Market because
Amazon you know I had in the mindset at
first it was like Google like if you're
not number one you're nothing but it's
not like that like on Amazon people
browse you can direct traffic to it it's
very different that way so I I it was
never that it was all about no this
opportunity he says let's see and as I
started doing the business model I
started feeling kind of I didn't like
selling people a weight loss supplement
when their respon is when i' you know
because I tried following up giving them
value saying as you buy this product you
know here's some exercise tips all that
and i' get responses like if I wanted to
exercise I wouldn't have bought your
product you know and so you just start
feeling guilty it's like well you know
as much as they say it works this isn't
really good for you so I've actually
gotten out of the health industry and
now I focus primarily on the house and
home but so I could see the trajectory
into Amazon for you and so and we'll get
more more specifically into you know
those aspects but I want I want to know
Mike's uh you know how did you arrive
here sure well I'll go back even a
little further and probably people don't
know this but I actually sold paint
right out of college paint yeah so I put
myself through college by working at a
paint factory that my dad worked at and
in the early '90s when I graduated the
job market was not there for anyone uh
luckily uh the factory called back up
and said you realize we have more jobs
other than just factory jobs we have
professional jobs uh and luckily I was
able to take a job with them no idea I
was going to be selling paint but uh I
took that and moved to Alabama and then
within a few months they realized that
computers were now all the rage in the
early 90s and Mike the you know 20-some
kid out of college must know computers
didn't uh but I vowed to learn them and
so I moved to Chicago uh really got into
the whole data analysis with the company
as computers were taking off uh and that
led me to another job of like once I
realized like data and computers was
where I wanted to go uh I got into cons
to Consulting business then um I started
traveling Consulting uh I found a client
that I was doing a lot of data analysis
with uh Telecom company uh and they
actually got me involved in the finance
side of it and so shortly thereafter I
became a finance director for a large
Telecom company what does that mean to
be a finance director like what kind of
stuff did you do yeah so I focused a lot
on the revenue recovery side where a
business you know you get so big you
don't realize where you're leaking money
right um you don't you just look at the
numbers the Top Line the bottom line you
don't realize that there's all these
little gaps and holes in your system so
my job was to find those gaps and plug
them and we did that with data uh and I
always loved research I love you know
analyzing what's coming in what's going
out and where's the Delta between those
two right uh and I really found that
that was a great spot for me and so
after doing that for the for them for a
while um I loved the work I was doing
but I felt chain down I was this guy
that sat in an office I had a team
working with me we're always looking you
know it's it was mostly cable at the
time cable did not have a really good
you know perception among people and so
I didn't have this feeling that I was
bringing joy to people's lives doing
anything like that and definitely not my
own life I had a lot of stress in that
job so it was a great you know great
group of people but I wasn't really
feeling fulfilled so then it was about
2012 I realized I wanted to do something
different I didn't want to have this
corporate job with this week or two of
vacation every year um you know I was
making good money but I was stressed out
not seeing my family and luckily you
know I saw an email come by talked about
hey there's great opportunity on Amazon
it must have been months after you know
Jason and Matt had started really you
know finalizing and fine-tuning how to
build a business in Amazon and I was one
of the first people to get this email
and it just really you know stoked
something inside of me to me realize
this seems like a good opportunity and I
remember you know hearing about the
training and it all just clicked you
know why why go out there and try to
invent a brand new product find
something that people already want
there's already a demand that's half the
equation of selling if you know that
there's a demand for something then
create something that fills fills that
demand or something that even does
better than that and that's what the
model taught me and so I jumped in I
took this you know I I learned how to
build my own business on Amazon how to
build a brand of products I products I
launched my first product was a leather
conditioner I didn't own anything made
of leather I'm actually looking for one
of those right now maybe I have to talk
to you about that after this good but I
knew I could Source in United States I
knew there was you know a low quantity
get going with the price was was right I
knew I could make a good profit margin
and most of all there's a demand for it
and not too much competition at the time
so I started off with that and lo and
behold a year later I was making enough
that I could actually quit my Corporate
Finance job in order to pursue this
full-time and it's just kind of taken
off from there and a lot of other things
happened since then as well yeah so and
I want to get into that in a moment but
when did the transition come from you
being a customer you know of the company
to actually coming into the company so
I'd say probably started about 6 months
after I started you know doing you know
learning how to build a business and we
we actually met in Austin for the first
time there was a live event for all all
the people learning how to this new
business model we got to meet for the
first time at that point it wasn't just
virtual community everyone talking on
Facebook or in a private group it was
six five 600 people in a room face to
face meeting Jason me meeting Matt and
then talking about all of our successes
our failures what was working what
wasn't working and what was amazing
about that not to use amazing again uh
was how much everyone was sharing with
each other yeah we had five 600 people
that you thought were competitors of
each other
but they're all helping each other out
because the the world out there is so
big there's so much demand for
everything there's no point in trying to
keep it all to yourself and so when I
started sharing more and more of what I
was finding out because it's face you
know two guys can't figure everything
out and do it all the time they're
they're running you know a large
business bring in all kinds of students
that need other people to help and so I
came in as more of a mentor in that role
there's probably a handful of us in that
and then after another six month of
doing mentoring then they realized we
need someone to help with training right
and so I came in and started doing
training about six months later
and then a few years down the road as it
was uh really building the Rapport the
relationship we're all you know we
realize we're in this together we're
helping change the world we're changing
lives we're building a great business
that's expanding Beyond Amazon and
Beyond just e-commerce uh real was you
know a better idea to bring me in
full-time to really help you know with
the business and the customer support
and also the building of the products to
make sure they're as good as they can be
yeah if I just want to add one thing on
that so what you know he's talking about
our events when our first event where
really surprised us and when he talks
about changing people's lives was that
fact and that's one of the reasons we
pulled Mike in too because he uh has a
lot of empathy for people and because
it's you know one thing to teach people
but if you're not relating to them if
you're not understanding them you can't
help them and at the end of the event we
had you know the whole room was lined up
around the room and it took us an hour
to go through if everyone wanted to take
a picture with me and Matt Shake our
hands and tell us how we changed their
lives so it was this spark that went in
my mind it's like I found my passion
we're changing people's lives and it
it's you know often times you hear about
passion Follow Your Passion find your
passion and I used to get stuck in those
mindsets of like how can I be passionate
about something like I got to find my
passion and you see people that are
Health experts and all that but it it's
when all of a sudden you find it and it
was changing people's lives the energy
it gave um and just the spark that we
saw in Mike and how he wanted to affect
people's lives and so um he's definitely
been an asset he's a very successful
seller of his own Brands but he's got a
real knack for being able to relate to
people and help teach them so it's been
a really good partnership so amazing you
know is legendary in the digital
marketing world because the size of some
of the launches you've done you know
it's people know about them um and it's
this whole concept of the virtual world
but what what gets my attention is hm
you decide to have a live event which is
like you know kind of like the other
direction a little bit so what was the
internal dialogue saying you know hey
this is all about how to be virtual and
and you know really build a good
business a profitable business virtually
let's get everybody together live so
what what was the impetus behind that
it's about camaraderie um and sharing
ideas and the fact that you know over
the seven years before that um I went
from being in an office to working in my
home and going through a lot of ups and
downs working from your home can have a
mental challenge at times you know you
get depressed you feel alone you don't
have people around you that can relate
you can bounce things off so it's really
about creating that community and we
also knew that we wanted to have an
experience so not only to help people
create a community but also to help
connect people that can help one another
one of the biggest things that me and
Matt did originally was we created this
Mastermind group and so I started
selling in October we had the Mastermind
group in November and then every one of
us in that Mastermind Group by February
were crushing it MH and so it really
opened our eyes too that you have to be
sharing as Mike said there's just too
much to teach um and so it was really
just about how do we create Community
with people how do we make people feel
they they belong and how do we get that
camaraderie so people feel that they're
not just on an island by themselves
doing this business that there's
actually something more to this and uh
it just worked it really did did you
have I guess this is really a question
for you because you're there at the
point in time but when you got together
with Matt and you said um you let's
let's put together this product and this
project and let's go launch this did you
anticipate the size it would be
no um you know I was going for you know
my target was the John Reese Frank Kar
kind of million dooll launch you know
the mic feel same kind of thing and what
we did originally what we launched was
three products in one it was originally
called the Amazon money machine and then
Amazon let us know that you can't do
that so we quickly changed it and
thankfully at that time you know we were
nobody so like we had time we changed it
to the amazing money machine and then
the amazing selling machine John ree
actually helped us change that but when
we started it we were focused on uh
private label wholesale Drop Shipping
and Kindle because those were the three
aspects of Amazon but after the year of
doing that in all the community
testimonials we were looking like yeah
people were making a few thousand
dollars a month with kle some were doing
okay with private lab uh with wholesale
private label we had people crushing it
we had one guy um David Paul Doyle
actually was one of our first guys that
um he's right now naturewise and he's
one of the biggest Health brands on
Amazon um he was one of our first
success stories and we just looked at
this it's like so by having this
training we should probably get rid of
the you know look at the 8020 what's
getting us 80% of our results was
private label and then so when we did
that and now we had these testimonials
you know you go from the first year
launching the product doing a million
dollars to the next launch we do do just
the launch itself in 9 days doing $7
million you know was kind of like whoa
and then the next launch you did 10 next
launch you did 16 then you do a $22
million launch and it was just it two
things happened number one we were the
first to Market we were the first real
established system but the other cool
thing is all of that pre-training I did
of creating communities courses all
those kind of things just fed right into
that so it was just really all those
relationships from Affiliates and
everything that I had it was like the
perfect storm and you know it it plays
with your mind too when all of a sudden
all this success comes it's like winning
the lottery um it really there's a lot
of challenges that come with that um a
lot of challenges but no I I I was
hoping for like A2 or three million
launch I had no idea it would do what it
did and the biggest launch was it 22
million was that the yeah so that's
that's a that's a lot more than
one yeah it was pretty incredible you
know but with all the people now that
have come in because obviously you
opened up this this kind of new frontier
that's an opportunity you know when I
look at it sometimes I think in terms of
um it's almost like uh learning
franchise you know as far as saying hey
there's there's kind of a turnkey
business method here that you can adopt
but franchises you need a lot of money
to be able to engage in here you need
very little investment to be able to
kind of get a product get a business get
the whole structure together and be able
to go to market and then you so if for
some reason didn't work you you don't
really have a downside or much of a
downside and if it does work it's it's a
terrific thing and we actually teach
that where um some people will you know
we we there's one person we were just
talking to that put like $116,000 in
their first inventory order and it's
like what are you doing like there
that's ABS you want to start as risk
adverse as possible and the idea is
start with a you know you you want to
start with about what two 300 units
that's about that's all you need for
really to get going you don't you don't
need to spend thousands of dollars as a
matter of fact you only started with
$500 worth you know got me about a 100
bottles of leather conditioner to you
know but you know and talking about risk
um you know we're in you're building a
business there's risk involved in it but
I like to think of it as calculated risk
you don't just go out there and blindly
spend money on something you don't feel
has a proven way of working out for you
and one of the things that you know we
probably the biggest thing we built up
is all this credibility social proof all
these success stories of people who've
made it work and all the reasons why
people who didn't weren't able to so we
know what not to do as well as what to
do which is really important you know
it's not just do this do this but here
don't do this it can you know be the
difference between success and failure
and that's why we have you one of the
challenges we have we have to keep it up
to date all the time and e-commerce is
changing every single day Amazon changes
every single day you can't open the
paper not read an article about Jeff
Bezos or about Amazon without seeing
something in the news uh about them
changing or expanding to a new business
or shutting down a part of the business
right we have to stay on top of that
because if we don't and we teach someone
to do something wrong that could hurt
their business big time in line with
that cuz I there's there's a question I
have relative to that cuz one might
think okay well now you've done this for
some years now you you've had all these
thousands of people who've come in are
doing it um is it saturated is there
still a lot of room for people to come
in where you where do you think you are
in that particular part of the arc yeah
if if you look at it saturation is a
state of mind there's there's absolutely
no way that a business or an entire
section of the economy that's growing so
big could be even come saturated yet
Amazon or e-commerce in general only has
a you know fraction percentage of all
retail sales I think it's not even over
15% of all retail yet so it's an
expanding Universe right absolutely you
know and and the way that it's growing
the number of sellers can't even keep up
to Pace with the the way that the amount
the market is taking over W um and
Amazon still does only about 50% United
States right now they can still grow
there they're expanding into other
markets other areas um and there's
always new products coming out it's a
constant you know continual flow of new
new ideas new products new me methods of
marketing that you can just take
advantage of you know but one thing is
the sooner you get in the more time you
have to take advantage of that's why we
always want people to get in as soon as
they can and people make the mistake of
thinking this is an Amazon business and
it's not it's a physical products
business but you're leveraging Amazon to
get started and the whole idea is once
you have a proven brand once you have
your proven products and there's so much
opportunity on Amazon like you said you
can expand internationally so easily
then you create your own e-commerce
store you start going on different
websites and you expand how your product
reaches but the world's changing I mean
just I was just telling about an article
I was reading where it listed all the
stores closing this year you know people
are GNA go somewhere to buy and then
people say well what if Amazon starts
selling all their own products well then
would you buy on Amazon you know if you
know if I only go to Amazon and you can
only buy Amazon Brand Products there I'd
start looking elsewhere right you know
because and Amazon doesn't want that
Amazon admits 50% of the revenue is from
third party sellers so there's so much
growth and it's just like a hockey stick
right now with how quick that Amazon is
uh expanding and some people think that
it it's oversaturated because I think
it's a fear like they want to talk
themselves out of it where they're
looking for
opportunities but they they almost seem
to Red Flag everything and no matter
what business model I've been teaching
that's the number one thing oh is it
oversaturated it's over feel like they
missed it yeah they feel like they
missed it and it doesn't matter that the
first year we started selling amazing
selling machine the the number one
question was is it too late is it too
late to get into it and the the the only
thing that determines success or failure
in my opinion the number one thing is
mindset going into it you know you hear
mindset you know some people say oh it's
irrelevant it's like it's not and every
success story we talk to the people say
right away this is I knew I could make
this work and so it's really believing
that if you're going into this and
saying this isn't going to you know the
the word try I think sometimes people
missuse like oh I'm going to try that
why don't you just do it don't just try
it do it implement it like fully go in
and it's even incredible sometimes
people buy our course and they'll
they'll send me their because they'll be
struggling they say let me see what
you've done it's like well you haven't
followed the training it's like well
well why are you doing this like you is
this a hobby for you because if it's a
hobby then I'll step back and it's like
you just go have fun but if you want to
change your life if you want to be a
real successful business then you can't
just try you have to do it and it's all
about mindset and at the end of the day
um there is so much room on the internet
for e-commerce whether it you know
Amazon right now is the Behemoth but you
remember when Google took over Yahoo
people were like there's no way like
Yahoo is going to be it then Google came
along like there'll be something come
along but the thing is people are always
going to need to buy there's always you
know whether it be you know and I love
it now like just the other day I ordered
a bottle opener cuz is like oh I got to
go buy a bottle it's like wait a sec you
know order it and same day deliver you
get it you know in the big so it's like
I'm just going to do more and more of
that and I think the world's turning
that way so it's really if you want to
change your life if you want to do a
business um look for the reasons why to
do it now be cognizant like obviously if
it's you know you want to look at the
market share and all those different
elements but at the end of the day um if
you want to change your life you just
got to take action and really believe in
yourself I'd say that you know any well
in line with that who's who who's the
avatar for you guys like this is the
ideal person or the ideal three types of
people that really are our customer it
started with this guy with really it and
the idea was because it worked from you
know um mid 40s middle-age kind of
person that had some disposable income
to be able to buy some inventory not a
lot and they were looking for something
else it was somebody that was stuck in a
job and they were just feeling like I
have to commute to the office it's
really like the commute could summarize
it like if you're sick of the commute
but it was more the middle-aged person
that was an executive that was looking
to to get that freedom but it's since
changed a lot yeah now we see people
from all walks of life too any I think
anyone who want to make a change in
their life and has a has a reason why
they want to do that you know and money
very seldom is the reason why it's what
you want to do with that money but if
you have a reason if you're wise you
want to spend more time with your family
you want to travel you want to you know
buy nice things there's nothing wrong
with that at all just you understand
what it is you're doing this for if you
have a reason why you want to make a
change that's our ideal person because
having a good reason why you want to
make this successful will help you be
successful and I and I know like number
one thing that got me successful was as
soon as I started I made the decision
that I was going to build this business
I didn't I didn't you know wonder what's
it going to be like when I'm successful
I started visualizing i' I've already
made the step I've already made a change
I'm already successful because I've
already taken that big leap now you're
full-time as an executive uh when you
started you said right yeah so cuz
that's one of the big questions is come
up how much time do I need to be able to
make this work I was nervous starting
out thinking how can I build an entire
brand in a business while you know
having two young kids at home having a
wife that you know she she needs
attention for me and vice versa so I
couldn't just you know ignore all those
things and having a full-time job that
had travel to uh luckily I was able to
do it within an hour or two a day so the
way that you know the training when I
when I took training to learn how to do
this it was laid out where you could
watch it anytime you wanted to it's on
online it's virtual uh support the help
the mentorship that's all virtual online
so anytime you wanted to go watch it I
usually my plan was work all day came
home I had dinner with the family then I
would go downstairs and I'd watch some
training for an hour or two and then I'd
come back upstairs and hang out with the
family a little bit more and then 10
o'clock I go back downstairs and spend
another 30 minutes to kind of plan up my
next day so it's never more than a
couple hours a day and but I think
what's important is that you had a kind
of a structure around the training in
other words uh it's probably not a I'll
get to it when I have time because that
probably never shows up yeah those are
the people that a year later they're
still we have people from asm4 they say
okay now I'm starting you know and that
was four years ago because you get
lifetime access so once you join you'll
keep getting all the upgrades and so
we'll have people starting now say now
I'm going to commit and it's like you
know it's just mindboggling at times
when you hear that because it's like why
didn't you made this financial
investment back then but it it's you
have to be able to do that you have to
be able to dedicate we recommend a
minimum of an hour a day um but really
like if you want to make it work two
hours a day is probably more realistic
like really to be able to get it done in
six months where if you dedicate two
hours a day in six months you'll have a
dramatic transformation and you'll know
at the end of those six months you
either because that's another thing one
of the things that we believe is that um
everybody can do this business not
everybody will want to do a business you
know a lot of times being an
entrepreneur there's a little bit more
responsibility in life because you're
more responsible for for everything in
the business and so after 6 months we do
occasionally have people that say no
this just really isn't for me so we
actually offer a guarantee on that that
if you're not you follow our system
after six months if you're not you know
if you've done everything and you're not
happy we'll refund you still because
sometimes people fall into that victim
um very very small percentage of people
do that but it's just an interesting
phenomenon because some people they
think that they want to be an
entrepreneur but then they don't it's
not for them it's not for them yeah so
another category of person I wonder if
this is right for which is on my mind so
I've got a a 22-year-old son who's a
senior in college you know Finance
economics major who you know looking at
going out into the job market saying hm
I wonder if I you know how do I go look
for jobs what am I looking for but then
he just comes back from a trip to London
and says you know I found a you know a
small gin over there that they don't
import over here I wonder there's a way
I can figure out how to import that over
here you're thinking about ways to take
products from one place bring them in
you distribute them to another audience
is someone like that that's like maybe
uh ready for the job market just the
Dyson like they're 29 years old now and
they're they're doing what half a
million a month half a million a month
in sales you know and half a million a
month and these are so who are who are
these people Channing and Justin Dyson
CH yeah we just had them in Hawaii for
some video are they College like you
just had a college or uh what well
Justin dropped out of college once he
realized how well the business was doing
right and I think that Channing uh she
now owns a beauty shop that she still
does some part-time work in but now
they're really just running their own
business selling all kinds of you know
Children's Apparel and different types
of products that for them they have
young kids uh they realize that you know
could we make something better could we
make something that we would want to buy
as parents and knowing that there's
hundreds of millions of parents out
there they were similar what your your
son was they wanted to bring something
different to the market um that they
knew there was a demand for and that
gave them their passion to really dig
into this business one of our early
success students John Gil um who you
know quickly became an eight figureure
seller um one of the things that he was
most dedicated to us for is how this
transformed his family because he taught
his son the business model and now his
son does better than him and he's like I
I feel safe now like my son is taken
care of um so absolutely you know and
the neat thing about this business is
you know we recommend that you start you
know when we teach you we try to teach
you the most effective way to get the
fastest results possible with the least
amount of risk as possible now there's
always some risk um but the reality is
if you only have $100 to start with you
can start with $100 it's just it's going
to take you a little bit longer to find
the right products because some types of
products will have minimum order
quantities so you might have to have
$1,000 for that product so keep looking
for another because the idea is just get
started with a product find a product on
Amazon that fits certain criteria so you
know that it's a good seller and if it's
proven on Amazon that's why we also sell
like if you're just starting out don't
start with a brand new product don't say
I have this idea it's going to do well
well if it's not selling on Amazon you
have this whole other hurdle that you're
going to have to figure out so what you
do is you find a product that's selling
well first of all you try to figure out
how to make it a little bit better
there's steps in this process so is that
the first step so finding the product is
the first step in the process the most
important one because your product is
everything I like to think of it as the
base of the entire business uh and
that's why we're very very careful about
the criteria we use we want to make sure
that it's priced to amount of price
because if it's too low of a price you
won't make enough profit if it's too
high of a price you can't afford enough
inventory right you also make sure that
uh the competition is at the right spot
on Amazon because if you have too much
competition you can't compete with
people that have unlimited Pockets to
spend outspend you but if there's not
enough competition there's a reason for
that that the product probably isn't in
demand out there uh you also want to
make sure that it's not too heavy
because let's face it shipping is a cost
of business nowadays and if you can
remove that from the equation then that
makes it much easier to get going and
then you also want to make sure that you
can private label it that's a big part
of what we talk about here so it's much
easier to take a product a generic
product uh think of a thermos instead of
selling the thermos brand thermos create
your own brand of it you know come up
with the the Mike and Jason's thermos or
whatever it is um Jason
mikeon and and brand that yourself
because if you own the brand you own an
asset and you're you're bringing cash
flow every month and you're building an
asset that at some point if you choose
to cash out and retire you have that
built up sell someone else's exact same
product you're building their business
right but if you s make your own you're
building an asset for you yeah and
that's a really important point a lot of
people ask two things like why don't I
just sell somebody else's brand to start
off well with Amazon you're allowed one
listing so let's say you know whatever
it is a
ACME spatulas um there's only one
listing on Amazon and then you'll see
underneath the buy box where you you
click the buy button other sellers so
then all of a sudden you'll notice that
there could be 50 others competing so
what's happening now everyone's driving
ding for the lowest price so now it's a
commodity product but when you're your
own seller you're the only listing you
might have Amazon cuz it depends on how
you have things set up they can resell
your used stuff so if someone returns
some but that's the only time you'll
have a competitor so it's it's just you
get all the profit you get all the sale
and so people think oh it's easier to
start this way and it's not do you ever
have a manufacturer decide to acquire
somebody who was white labeling saying
hey you know this is really good I like
this brand of my product uh I think I'll
buy you so I haven't had that but I had
have them went to partner with us and
several other people as well so once
they see like uh like your example with
your your raspberry ketones where they
could have very easily came to you and
said Jason let's partner on this we'll
give you a better deal let's share in
the profits um I had one of my suppliers
came to me after seeing the growth and
wanted to partner on a whole new line
with them um they do want to do that
sometimes um you don't have to do that I
mean again they're they're really happy
bring a manufacturer knowing that they
have someone out there who knows what
they're doing selling their products
because that's what they do best they
manufacturer they distribute them to
their the third party Sellers and then
let us do what we they'll stay in their
Lane so now okay so Step One is finding
the product what's step two next one
then is seeking the manufacturers
finding them uh and this is what blew my
mind when I first learned the business
model I thought that if I was buying any
kind of product out there that whoever
made maybe it was a Rayovac Lantern I
thought Rayovac made that product they
had a plant somewhere in St Louis and
they're they're turning out lanterns
ends up there's you know 100 plants in
China all making similar lanterns
and their private label and branding for
you so the first thing is to find a
supplier from usually overseas or if
you're selling like a beauty product or
some kind of health supplement in the
United States you need to find those
suppliers that are looking for you and I
didn't realize you could even do this I
didn't know that was a possibility um I
wasn't aware of private labing at that
point in time but nowadays you can go
online to sites like alibaba.com go even
Google and search for private label
products and you will see hundreds not
thousands of different suppliers that
actually are looking for you to sell
their products for them it's so much
easier today with Freight forwarders and
you know a lot that's a big concern
people have okay well how do I get the
product from China to here it's so easy
it's really just a matter of picking up
the phone talking to the freight
forwarder they ask all the right
questions I don't even know if all of
them need a phone there's probably
online forms now and they'll take
they'll make sure it goes from the
manufacturer right to Amazon so it
really we don't recommend this but you
could start and run this business
without ever touching the product
yourself ever now we always recommend
get a sample make sure you check the
product um but you really don't need to
it uh yeah yeah yeah I don't see any of
our products anymore well when we're
creating the products I know for Our
Brands like we obviously I'm sure you do
this too you look at the product you buy
the competitors you compare them you
feel them you see how you can make it
better and then that's it you know and
then the only other time is uh launching
a new product launching a new yeah yeah
you don't have to have a warehouse or
anything so that's step two what's step
three step three then is your piece of
property or real estate on Amazon like
Jason mentioned earlier uh every product
has a listing we call on Amazon it's
like it's almost like have your own mini
Weare your mini website on Amazon um
what you want to do is you want to make
sure that as many people as possible
that go to Amazon if they see your
product they want to buy their product
um and so there's very specific criteria
you want to have the best images
possible you want to have the best title
possible to make sure that it gets a lot
of uh traffic and but also doesn't look
spammy looks like a product that i' to
buy at the store you want to make sure
that you have plenty of details in the
bullet points those those five points
right below the name of the product and
you want to have a good product
description as well and there's you know
there's it's not overly complicated but
there's a formula for making sure you
have all four of those in place and
there's a fifth one there's kind of a
secret one that most people don't when
you're buying on Amazon don't realize
Amazon in the back end has these hidden
Search terms that if you want your
product to show up for other searches
that aren't in the title aren't in your
listing you can put them back there too
oh well yeah we had uh at one of our
Live Events we had someone come on stage
Agee and be vulnerable because they
showed us their product and we looked at
it audited it it was actually Mike that
did it he suggested oh do this in your
backr the next day sales are up 20% wow
just by optimizing it right and one of
the things with the did they say thank
you or uh they did they're very
successful now too they have uh and it's
really cool how now that with their
success they're paying back um and
they're treating in third world
countries people with eyesight issues so
they're it it's a very cool story but
with the the the one thing to keep in
mind when you're creating your listing
on Amazon is when people can go into a
store and touch and feel the product you
have to try to figure out how to give
them that experience virtually so your
pictures have to be we call them
lifestyle images think of the person and
a good way to do this is look at your
competition first of all and see what
people are complaining about and if you
can create a picture that negates that
so let's say someone it's a spatula and
someone says oh it broke on me well if
you had a picture showing them bendit
for example you know unbreakable but
really you just want to get in the
person's mind try to get that person
able to visually see themselves using
the product and it makes a huge
difference and use video also to that
you can now yeah Amazon has allowed that
video is obviously super powerful yeah y
what's step four uh the final step is
then launching your product so this is
where we can really beat the big Brands
you'll think the major brands out there
like Nike or Adidas or whoever just
selling on Amazon you think they'd have
these huge marketing departments that I
go out there and they do a huge launch
on Amazon to them Amazon is just another
Channel another sales Channel they just
put a product up there and they hope
that people come buy it because their
popularity well the way that Amazon
looks at products nowadays is that there
are certain triggers certain levers you
can pull and if you know what those
levers are and those triggers you can
get your product ranking very quickly
usually within a week or two and and
involves it's it's not overly
complicated either it involves you know
getting your product live on a certain
date uh getting some targeted focused
traffic to the product really focusing
on people that you believe are more
prone to want your product do you drive
that from outside of Amazon or within
both internal external I mean Amazon has
well Amazon's investing $15 billion do
this year in tools for sellers just like
us wow and those tools all to really
narrow in on people buying on Amazon
based upon their their interest their
age their demographics the type of
products they want but in addition of
that Facebook makes advertising so easy
too you can also drill down to the
demographics to your exact target
customer and once you find that match
you have a product and you have a person
that you know wants that product that
traffic will convert and then as soon as
Amazon sees a product converting this is
where that it's a Snowball Effect if
someone goes to your product and buys it
andon says wow this is a popular product
let's move them up in search rankings
that happens again they move up in the
search rankings and if you know how to
make those those those triggers get
pulled and and and and activated um it's
pretty simple now to rank a product on
Amazon within a couple of weeks of
launching it the the big thing though
the Crux of this all is you have to have
a good product and it doesn't mean like
a good product doesn't mean it's the
most expensive product but it's just
look at what you're giving the user and
make sure you're fulfilling on that so
whether it's a spatula or something much
more complicated um just make sure that
it's a solid product because if it no
marketing can help a bad product you
might launch and do really well but then
once the negative reviews come in you're
done and another tip too especially for
people wanted to start um from scratch
is start with a simple product because
if you're like let's say you want the
difference between a spatula and I don't
know a phone like any kind of electronic
is one of them is going to give you a
headache because you're going to be
dealing with all these different
departments for manufacturing you're
going to be dealing with uh reviews
because of this electronic part doesn't
work but if you start with something
simple it helps you get going learn the
system implement it and then from that
point that's the other thing you might
start with a spatula and end up selling
baby supplies well and that's a really
interesting point or a question I have
what's the experience typically when
somebody succeeds to a single product
are they normally then moving to build
the next one and the next one or people
focus product is a curse yeah because
people can get I don't want I hate using
the word lazy that's not complacent or
they think they're better than they are
yeah that too like that is actually you
know it's and we have people with one
product doing hundreds of thousands a
month and we keep asking them when are
you going to add your next product and
you know they just they're doing so well
with their lifestyle and it's like
that's a risk it's all about calculated
risk again you know so there's three
ways to really grow you can sell more of
that same product you can launch more
products or you can expand in other
markets and the easiest one is to sell
that same product and people kind of
fall into that trap and it's easy to do
because the cash comes in quicker than
the end of the way but the first step I
would do is if youve started if you if
You' started a product that you know
there's a demand for simply expand into
that same category come up with a
complimentary product instead of a
spatula come up with a fork cuz I'd have
to imagine on a sort of on a Decay curve
you know if you've got a single product
that you've been selling a lot of for
some period of time over it's got over
time absolutely life cycle yeah and
sometimes people get lucky they get a
long long time out of it but I know all
of the products that I started
originally selling now are not my top
sellers some of them we don't even sell
anymore and that's another thing people
seem to make this mental commitment that
I have this product oh it's going to be
forever and it's like no you can't look
at that like it's a business you're
building and you want to build and
that's why we say build a brand because
if you've got you know whe if it's a
spatula well build a brand about that so
that you can start relating you know
Build That Home Improvement brand or the
kitchen brand because then all your
community
you start build because you got to build
an audience at the end of the day and if
you're trying to sell a spatula plus you
know some kind of um baby equipment and
then some kind of outdoor you've got
this disjointed message but if you can
keep everything within one kind of Niche
it's just so much more effective would
you say the value then is more in the
brand than it is in the product longterm
Absolut longm longterm because now you
you can launch other products under that
brand and then you you have existing
customers that you can convert into the
new product I can't tell you how many
times that we've launched a new product
and before doing any marketing we start
selling them because you have you have a
brand you have an audience who trusts
you you know as long as you have a
quality product uh you provide Stellar
customer service you will build some
raving fans out there that'll be
advocates for you I have people who
respond to a negative review that are
customers of M even before I get a
chance to because they want to say hey
if you contact to the company did you
tell them about your problem did you
give them a chance to take take care of
it nine times out of 10 they haven't um
and it's nice to see Advocates you build
up that camaraderie with your own
customers awesome yeah so as we're
having this conversation in my own mind
I'm sitting here thinking hm I could
think of three four five different
things that that this could be kind of
fun and incidentally this sounds like
fun to me sometimes I I hear things that
sounds like work and of course effort
and work is involved in anything that's
going to be successful but this sounds
like kind of fun too like I'm I'm I'm
getting tickled by some H you I wonder
if this would work I wonder if that
would work you know different products
different passions what have you so
what's a proper expectation like
somebody's watching us they're saying
hey I I this is a whole new universe to
me and it is really this a universe of
its own right I think got an idea or two
I I should start researching Etc what's
the right expectation for somebody
saying I'm I'm starting at square one
right now um you know what should I
expect as as far as outcomes of course
you've talked about some pretty extreme
examples of su successful people but
let's talk typical so I mentioned six
months and that kind of how we design
the course the idea is now you get
lifetime access to it always upgrades
but we the course is is delivered over
eight weeks but we realize in eight
weeks you know you probably don't even
have your product in inventory yet
because you know the first few weeks is
all about finding your product and then
once you order your product depending on
where you get it from if you get it uh
domes like within the United States for
example you could have in a week uh but
if you get it from China sometimes the
lead time depending on the time of year
you could be you know up to eight weeks
it could be a couple of months um so
really we figure about three months from
the time you start to how you have your
inventory and then the next three months
launching the product so that six months
is really a good time frame but that
means six months of working one to two
hours a day right um and and I think
that's very realistic and at the end of
those six months um no matter what the
level of success you'll know whether
this is working for you or not because
um you're right it is fun you know and
it's it in a way it's kind of like the
stock market in a way because you're
watching these graphs and you're buying
and selling stuff and just watching how
it improves and you know it's all the
the science the analytics behind really
interest
so yeah I can't tell you how many times
that like on the weekends when I you
know get together with family and
friends I'm talking about this business
it's addictive it really is we talk
about it all the time you know we do a
lot of training but we still talk about
products and ideas and new launch
strategies we're always thinking of
something new to help out people to get
better results and then we we spend a
lot of our own money and time testing
things out we've wasted a lot of money
testing things out but but there's a
reason
invest we call it tuition yeah no no now
someone want to realize like you know
after six months what can they expect
like financially the way that we try to
to narrow in and give people advice on
where to like start with a product don't
go for a product's going to make a
million dollar a month don't go for a
product's going to make you $10 a month
you want something very reasonable and
realistic and and achievable so we
target products that should get you
anywhere from10 to $25,000 in Revenue a
month what's the typical margin on that
Revenue uh 25% okay so that's that's
great we don't want you going any lower
than 25% because then you've got
marketing costs and things and you want
to be able to put money in your Pock the
other important thing on that too is we
recommend give it a full year um and if
you like if you're working already make
your plan to work the whole year because
what you want to do initially when you
sell is reinvest 100% everything back
into because you want to you know you're
GNA once it takes off it's going to take
off you're going to run out of inventory
you're going to be panicking all these
kind of things but it's like settle down
that's part of the process but the thing
is if you're trying to spend all your
profit right away you're not going to be
able to reinvest and grow so that that's
one thing to keep in mind but um yeah
within I'd say that's pretty reasonable
biggest successes we've seen are those
people who've taken their profits they
realize potential this business has and
they put it right back in the more
inventory they do that a couple times
around and then they put it into a new
product and then after a year year and a
half um then you can really make the
decision how much do I want to pull out
for myself for my lifestyle for my why
and then how much do I want to continue
putting back in the business so that
continues that steady climb upwards yeah
and it's important to realize this isn't
a hack this isn't a um any of those
short-term things you're building a
brand you're building your own physical
products brand and we're teaching you
how to do that by leveraging Amazon to
explode it you know and so you're
building a real business so any business
takes time but if you look at the the
comparison of trying to start a business
anywhere else outside of Amazon compared
to on Amazon it's incredible it really
is I have to tell you know what excites
me about this is there's so many times I
speak to people who want to become
entrepreneurs you know sometimes called
entrepreneurs right you they'll they'll
take some training they'll learn some
things but there's not a really a good
path for them to leverage things
tools Amazon environments what have you
uh where they have the money you know
the investment that they can make to get
something moving or at least test
something to see if it's even viable so
what excites me about this is like sure
if I want to open up XYZ franchise yeah
you know you got a million and a half $2
million dolls you know and you can get
approved for it Etc you can go and get
your franchise and it's a pretty good
TurnKey business model Etc but in this
case it's like I don't need you know I
just need a little bit of capital and
some time to get this started to see if
I can throw my hat in this ring and get
it going and a huge component that we're
seeing exploding right now is selling
businesses so the Amazon uh there are so
many people looking to buy Amazon
businesses that we're having you know
four five time multiples easy of people
who are getting you know High eight fig
buyouts of a business that they started
on $1,000 because they've created this
only a year or two ago yeah and they're
only selling on Amazon well see now
that's even more fascinating then
because and I think a huge benefit cuz
it's one thing to say hey I I'm able to
build a cash flow business means I get
to make some money over time that I can
pull out of it but if you're saying that
you're also building an asset that's
that's salable that's extraordinarily
attractive especially because if you got
some some good history and financials
you can get good multiples on a business
like that yeah and so what I'm doing
right now personally with my physical
products brand I don't take any money
out of it I focus it all 100% back in
because my plan is in 3 to five years I
want to sell it for a cash out so that
it helps me my next phase of life so and
that's maybe I'll call it a real
business versus a lifestyle business
corre and there's nothing wrong with
either you it's not lifestyle businesses
aren't bad but you know if you're really
looking to be a business builder then on
tax side I guess you're paying capital
gains on that as compared to regular
income when you make that transaction so
you there's a whole bunch of benefits to
that you know the great thing about this
too is you don't have to make the
decision right away you don't have to go
in wanting either cash flow or lifestyle
or a combination of both you can decide
that as you get into the business we do
know a lot of people who want the
lifestyle business okay Mak an extra
couple thousand doar a month in in pure
income so they can travel they can pay
their house payments they can get an
extra car and in order to maintain that
type of Lifestyle business you can keep
going just on a couple hours a week once
you have your product up and selling
it's really just keeping track of
customer you know uh questions and
making sure inventory is in stock if you
want to grow it and turn it into a brand
that you want to sell as an asset yeah
you have to put more time into it it's a
real business that's what I love about
it's a real business you can have both
components yeah I I I just one caveat I
want to add there so for example right
now I work 90 minutes a week on my
Amazon business that's it because I have
employees now you can't do that I don't
want someone listening to say oh I can
work just a couple hours a week well no
no no you'll get to that point when you
start you have to invest the time you
have to get things in place you have to
then get the employees um involved but
then it gets to a point you're right
that's all you have to do is a couple
hours a week you know it's always wise
to know what's going on in your business
but it's one of those things you can set
up hire Outsource ners Employees Family
whatever you want it's very doable
that's awesome one of the things that
we're offering as a bonus for wealth
breakthroughs is something that is new
for you this this book that you have
created that really gets into the
details of what we just talked about so
let's talk about that book sure this is
the first time we've actually done this
we've created a book that you know talks
a lot about what we talked about today
the basic training how to start your own
Amazon business but it goes into much
more detail we'll go through all the
exact steps all the pitfalls to look for
uh the ways to you know other tricks and
tips that we've learned over the years
you know we we don't always teach tricks
and tips but we've included them in this
book because we know these are little
things that will help you along get get
going faster even better we've included
that all in the book uh everyone's going
to get that for free and it'll walk
through the entire process of finding
the product finding a supplier creating
that perfect product listing on Amazon
and then launching it so you can start
making sales immediately all in one book
that you'll get shipped to you I think
this is a phenomenal high value bonus
for wealth breakthrough so I really
appreciate you uh offering that for our
audience you're welcome well I have to
say this has been a really great Peak
into a universe of of real potential for
people that maybe don't have other paths
open to them so uh your Your Enthusiasm
is palpable so I appreciate you coming
here and sharing it and sharing it so
openly so thank you very much for this
time you're welcome it was a pleasure to
be
here hi there and welcome to your
episode 9 bonus interview mark lenfield
from the Oxford Club is here to show you
why every investor should invest for
income first and build the rest of their
portfolio around this simple Timeless
strategy if you think this is going to
be a snoozer of a conversation about
Blue Chip dividends you're in for a big
surprise here's
[Music]
mark
so mark thank you so much for being with
us this morning yeah thanks for having
me so tell me a little bit about who you
are and what it is that you do sure so
I'm the chief income strategist at the
Oxford club and I run our income
franchise uh and that consists of
wealthy retirement our free e-letter uh
the Oxford income letter which is our
monthly newsletter that's focused on
generating income and uh and and the
goal the main goal of the Oxford income
letter is to generate more income today
than we did last year and more next year
than we will this year so it's all about
income growth uh and obviously we we're
striving for capital gains too but it's
really about increasing the income uh
that members receive uh year after year
so I I want to get into that
specifically but how in the world did
you end up here is it was this your
career trajectory not at all had a very
unconventional uh entry into Finance so
when I was in school I wanted to be a
sports caster and um that was I can see
that yeah that that was the plan and
then I got out of school and realized
what I would have to do the kind of dues
you'd have to pay and I wasn't I I grew
up right outside of New York and I
wasn't uh I wasn't willing to be the the
number three weekend anchor person uh in
you know in a city I'd never been to um
and then hope that you can then get to a
slightly larger market and a slightly
larger market and I knew people in the
industry and saw what they had to go
through and and some very talented
people who were then 40 45 50 years old
who still de Mo yeah exactly and and
nothing wrong with De Moine but um you
know I either wanted to be you know big
time in New York and and doing NFL games
or uh or I didn't want to do it and I
just didn't I didn't see a path um that
that uh that I could I could be happy
with um it just you know there are
certain things in my life I paid my dues
and very willingly done it including in
finance which I'll get to in a minute um
and that wasn't one of them and I
luckily I realized that before um I got
too far into it so um from there I
actually uh decided I'd be an actor and
uh I was spending all of my free time
studying the markets though I I became
fascinated with the markets uh my
grandfather had had a a seat on the New
York Stock Exchange and and even though
when I was in college I had no interest
as soon as I got out of college uh I did
have uh a lot of interest in it and
really I would read everything I could
get my hands on I would spend hours on
the weekends in the library um back when
people went to libraries because there
was no internet and eventually after
several years decided to make my hobby
which was investing uh into my career
and make my career which was acting into
a hobby uh so I I switched it um but as
you can imagine there weren't a lot of
job openings
for uh 28-year-old actors right uh on
Wall Street so um at the time I was
living in San Francisco and I found
there was a company that uh they were a
trading firm a very small trading firm
it was a 10-minute walk from my house
and they needed an assistant on the
trading desk so I went in handed my
resume I looked at it I had absolutely
no relevant experience
and and I could see what was happening
in in the room there were four Traders
and at the time the Traders didn't enter
their own orders that's what the
assistant was for um and they didn't
have this assistant and so they're
yelling orders at at the manager uh who
was trying to talk to me and and entered
the orders at the same time so I could
see that they really needed somebody
desperately so he looked at my resume
and said okay we'll we'll call you uh
and I knew they weren't going to call me
so I said I'll tell you what I'll stay
here this is on a Monday I'll I'll stay
here today and work for the rest of the
week for free uh if you don't think I
can do the job on Friday tell me don't
come back you know I can see you need
somebody so I'll help you out for the
week there was an offer he couldn't
refuse so uh so I did it and um on
Friday afternoon he said all right come
back Monday and I think I think I was
going to make $500 a week um and that
that was the entrance to my uh my career
in investing and trading wow so you you
started out in the fire
oh yeah so I had I had these Traders you
know screaming orders at me um so not
only did I have to enter the orders
confirm the orders then at the end of
the day I had to um do the books make
sure that their orders were right and
you know if I made a mistake I it it
cost them money uh and these these guys
also became my friends it was you know a
small office about four or five people
so if I did make a mistake I felt
terrible I mean luckily it didn't happen
very often but um there was one time
where I mean I cost a good friend of
mine several thousand dollars
and um yeah so I was in the fire for
sure uh but it it taught me so much
about the markets I can't I I can't
imagine a better education for the
markets had I had I been a finance major
or accounting major anything uh this
this was the best way to learn about
what actually happens in the markets
yeah some of the best Traders I've ever
met didn't have school it's it's um you
know I used to do Golden Gloves boxing
and we
before that I had taken Judo in karate
and you know you can practice in a dojo
but I learned more in a minute in a ring
in Leck Texas with a kid actually trying
to hit me in the face that where all you
know it's accelerated learning and
that's I I'm picturing that with you as
you know entering a trading floor so how
did you get from there to specializing
in
income um
so I was I kind of came of age during
the doom boom and and uh came of age you
know professionally so I was living in
San Francisco during the doom boom
that's when you know the stock market
became the national Pastime and stocks
were going up every day and people were
quitting their jobs to trade uh you know
dotom stocks and and you couldn't lose
and uh it it was really very much a
bubble um and I was pretty aware of it
but um still caught up in it um Bubble
popped um I ended up moving to Florida
and then I was there during the real
estate bubble and South Florida was one
of the the hottest markets in the
country as far as the real estate bubble
and the kind of the same thing happened
again and this time I was keenly aware
that this was happening and um I really
wanted to find a strategy where this
wouldn't keep happening where I wasn't
going to not only me but readers um
weren't going to get caught up in these
these Bubbles and get blown up and and
the more I studied the more I realized
that um dividend paying companies
particularly companies that raise their
dividend every year uh they outperform
the markets they are safer than the
broad market and they provide a nice
little buffer in bare markets because
you are getting that dividend and uh and
they they just over the longterm is a
long-term strategy uh you can't beat it
um I wrote a book called get rich
dividends and in the book I um did a
study and if you look at 10year periods
rolling 10-year periods starting in
1927 um the market as a whole has gone
up 91% of the time over 10 year periods
and you really had to have sold in the
heart of the Great Depression or in the
Great Recession to not make money in the
broader markets if you look at companies
that um raise their dividend every year
you never lost money over 10 years so
you know so I I believe that investing
longterm in the markets is a great
strategy and
then you you're basically you know kind
of accelerating your returns if you're
investing in companies that raise their
dividend every year um and and kind of
once once I saw the data and the numbers
uh I knew that this was a strategy that
I wanted to invest in personally because
I've I've seen the ups and downs of
trading hot stocks um which I I still
enjoy doing but for the long-term
strategy and for really growing your
wealth that's that's the best way to do
it and and and it's a strategy I feel
very comfortable recommending for most
investors because it is um it's it's
safer than a lot of investing strategies
that are out there going from the
trading desk to um suddenly you know
being writing for the Oxford uh
newsletter what you know what happened
in that inum period sure so uh during
the com boom I went to work for a DOT
startup that was all about financial
news we were a little ahead of our time
we were trying to be CNBC on the web uh
doing streaming video and audio problem
was nobody really had Broadband back
then right so we were a little ahead of
our time and and like a lot of Dooms we
didn't make it but but I was doing
Financial journalism and from there um I
became a salside analyst and that was
one of the most besides for the the time
on the trading desk that was is one of
the most um important parts of of my
career so I don't know what that what's
a sal sal side analyst is so if you hear
that Goldman Sachs or Morgan Stanley uh
is initiating coverage on a company or
upgrading a stock to buy or downgrading
it to sell those are the sell side
analysts um so the buy side are the
mutual funds the hedge funds those are
people that are buying stock sell side
are the Morgan Stanley's the the Goldman
Sachs they are trying to sell stock so
either you know they they make their
recommendations their Brokers tell their
clients they tell their their
institutional clients as well that that
they should buy the stock um and there's
a lot of conflict of interest you might
remember during the doom boom a lot of
the Dooms were recommended with buyer
ratings while the analysts were secretly
saying that they were garbage because
they were getting Investment Banking
fees so there's a lot and and that still
exists today despite there's supposed to
be rules and regulations that there're
supposed to a wall between investment
banking and research and that's garbage
that it it doesn't exist The Firm that I
worked for did not have an investment
banking arm so and was known as a very
contrarian firm which means they really
went against the grain so we were only
allowed to make a recommendation if it
was Against the Wall Street consensus
other because we were small so if
Goldman Sachs is saying buy Cisco
Systems and we say buy Cisco Systems
well why is anybody going to pay
attention to us so uh we would only um
cover let's say Cisco Systems if if it
was a cell rating if everybody else was
saying by um now just to be clear we
didn't we didn't be contrarian just for
the sake of being contrarian but when we
found something that that um went
against the consensus and the other
thing to understand about the cell side
analysts is they don't have a lot of
incentive to stick their necks out and
make a bold prediction so if you're an
analyst at more Stanley and there are 10
analysts on Wall Street that are saying
buy Cisco Systems and you say sell and
you're wrong you're going to have a lot
of explaining to do because everybody
else got it right um so being at this
Boutique firm where we were fiercely
contrarian um really taught me how to
research a company and really question
management and question the financial
statements and not
accept uh the Wall Street consensus and
again understanding that there might be
Investment Banking conflict of interests
uh so to really question everything so
now when I make recommendations it's
still with that that eye I mean that
that training that I got uh at this uh
firm called it was called Avalon
research group uh you you couldn't you
couldn't ask for better training I don't
know how I could have possibly gotten
better training anywhere else in the
world uh the director of research was
was brilliant and just this Uber
contrarian you know questioned
everything and um anytime I came into
him I mean I had to and wanted to make a
recommendation I had better be prepared
to defend it very very hard because he
was going to poke every hole he could
into it just like he would any other
research report coming out of Goldman
Sachs so um so then from there um I had
another uh quick stop at the street.com
where uh I wrote basically using this
contrarian Outlook and I wrote um some
columns on on a bunch of stocks really
poking holes and made a lot of enemies
there for a short period of time not at
at the street but at on some these
companies and then came to the oer club
perfect training yeah it really was um I
I'm so lucky I mean so much of of life
is is luck and much put into it and I
was so lucky that I ended up at this
this one firm to really open my eyes and
and show me kind of how companies in
Wall Street really works versus kind of
what you see on on CNB or or in the
mainstream media so it's funny um
sometimes we get lost on our path to
where we want to go and what people
really
want in in their retirement in their you
know in building their wealth you know
the target is really income that's what
affects your life the money that you can
use for your life but we think we have
to build this massive pile of assets to
somehow get the income when you can
actually just go straight St after the
income so and and and the income also
can if you're if you're at the point
where you're still growing your wealth
where you don't need the income today if
you're working having that income uh
compounds the wealth building machine if
you're reinvesting the dividends and
whatnot so um it's a great way of
growing wealth too it's not just about
getting that check and being able to
cash it uh if you're if you're still
working it's it's a great way I mean it
really um it really accelerates
the the wealth building um machine
essentially so let let's look at a
couple of scenarios for people that um
that you're writing for um you let's
look at kind of an outlier at a somebody
who's smarter than I was at 30 and
actually wants to assemble real wealth
over his lifetime how what would be a a
path you'd set them on so I would
strongly recommend that they invest in
these uh what I call Perpetual dividend
raisers companies that raise their
dividend every year and you reinvest the
dividends automatically and I don't want
to say set it and forget it because I
don't think you can ever just blindly uh
you know be blind to your Investments
you can't do that but you really don't
want to overtrade and one of the things
that uh that I I try to do with a lot of
the companies I recommend a lot of them
are are a little bit beaten up uh and
sometimes for very good reason uh but
these are companies that still generate
plenty of cash flow um they are paying
and raising their dividend every year so
perhaps their their business isn't isn't
white hot at the moment for example uh
number of years ago I recommended Darden
they're the restaurant operator of Olive
Garden and a few other right restaurants
and Olive Garden was kind of like the
butt of a joke at that point and their
traffic was down and it it just wasn't
going great but like I said they had
plenty of cash flow uh the business was
was it wasn't great but it wasn't
terrible and they were paying and
raising the dividend every year and I
said if this company ever gets its ship
writed this is going to be a monster uh
and sure enough it it took a couple of
years and and that's one of the things I
I try to emphasize to the readers of the
Oxford income letter we're not looking
for huge gains in the next three months
if it happens wonderful you know
certainly not going to turn take credit
for it yeah but uh but that's not the
goal the goal is to buy cheap stocks and
get paid those dividends and if you're
reinvesting those dividends and they're
and they're they stay cheap for a while
then you're just getting more and more
shares so the idea is eventually at some
point in the
future you do have this pile of assets
you have a ton of shares because you've
been reinvesting the dividends and then
hopefully then you can turn off the
reinvesting machine just collect the
dividends as your income and and
hopefully not touch the principle and
and if you did have to touch the
principle then hopefully you're selling
a lot less of it than you would if uh
you know if you weren't reinvesting the
the dividends for all those years but I
mean I've seen the numbers and if you
can reinvest dividends for 10 20 30
years uh you know you're talking about
uh a real shift in your lifestyle and
your comfort level and being able to
sleep at night and worrying about
retirement and you know I've I've seen
the numbers I've talked to people who'
have done that one of my dad's good
friends who's well into his 90s when my
book came out he said oh I've been doing
this since I was 40 and he said I never
touched my principal and uh you he
doesn't live like a king but he goes out
to dinner whenever he wants to he goes
on vacation when he wants to and he can
do it forever yeah because he's he's
never touching his principal he's just
living off the dividends which have been
compounding for uh I think for in his
case it was about 30 years so let's look
at another use case that and somebody
who um has waited too long they're 58
they're 62
suddenly retirement years are looming
and they um may have gotten wiped out in
in real estate they're just they're not
where they thought is it too late for
that person no not at all uh so there's
a couple things you have to look at one
is risk so if you I always say if you
can't afford to lose any money then it
should not be in the markets no matter
no matter what your situation and if you
you know and you feel like you have to
make make up for time or or previous
losses if you can't put if you can't
risk it at all it shouldn't be in the
market and unfortunately if if you can't
take risk your your return is going to
be extremely low especially in today's
uh low interest rate environment but
it's you know if you can't risk it you
can't risk it um as I mentioned
investing in these kinds of companies
tend to be safer than than the broader
Market but we do have bare markets from
time to time and if a lot of people
panic when markets go down and uh and
and sometimes you just have to withdraw
the money for whatever reasons and if
the Market's down 30% uh even if you
weren't planning to withdraw but now you
have to that that can be a real problem
so uh so you have to understand the risk
and be able to be invested for at least
I say if you need the any money within
three years it shouldn't be in the
market so at least five years preferably
longer that being said if you can invest
that way um then investing in these
Perpetual dividend raisers because even
if you if you if if you are compounding
if you are reinvesting great that helps
uh build your wealth a little bit faster
than you would normally but even if you
need the income today like I said
earlier you're still getting more income
today than you would last year and what
I shoot for with the Investments
generally I'm looking for about 10%
dividend growth every year not every
stock has that but that's that's the
goal so if you can get a 10% raise every
year or even even if it's 8% uh and
inflation is is still fairly low you're
increasing your buying power and that's
that's really the the goal of all of
this is just increase your buying power
after inflation every year and if you
can do that then you're in better shape
than you were yesterday so um you know I
like the idea of of somebody else doing
the research for me and you know like I
like the you know the thought that
you're you're in your your room on your
computer studying and picking these out
but How could somebody um these type
dividend stocks you're talking about how
can somebody research and find them on
their own what's uh so there is a a list
called the dividend Aristocrats uh now
these are S&P 500 companies that have
raised their dividends uh every year for
at least 25 years not all of them have
great yields I mean some of them might
have actually very small yields um
because the stock has gone up or or for
or they just don't pay a very large
dividend U but that's a that's a good
place to start uh because there are a
few of them that do pay 3 4% yields um
and and again these are S&P 500
companies so if you want to go smaller
uh you can do a search there are some
other places there's a a website it's a
free website uh it's drip investing. org
DRP investing. org and they have an
Excel spreadsheet that they publish
every month that lists all the companies
that have raised their dividends for
five years or more and uh that's a
that's an excellent place to start and
it has has a lot of information it's
probably more information than most
investors need it's it's a pretty long
Excel spreadsheet but at the very least
you can see the list of companies and
there's there's several hundred
companies that have been raising the
dividend every year for at least five
years and is is that kind of the Target
that you're looking for is 3 to 4%
dividend um at
least more towards 4% um so the the goal
of the Oxford income letter and in my
book I created a system called the 10
112 system and the idea is that if we're
collecting the income today that we want
11% yields within 10 years if we're
reinvesting the dividends then we're
shooting for 12% average annual total
returns uh over 10 years doesn't mean
you're necessarily going to get it in
the first year but because of the
compounding over 10 years you should get
so to do that it's it's a combination of
a starting yield and uh and the dividend
growth plus the assumption that the
market is going to go up uh by the
historical average which is about 7 and
a half percent a year so you know if
you're if you're starting at a 3%
starting yield you need that dividend
growth to be fairly high if you're
starting at four 4 and a half% then the
growth can be a little bit lower um so I
tend to look for at least 4% yields
because there's not a lot of companies
that are growing the dividend or that I
can expect to grow the dividend let's
say 15% a year over 10 years that's uh
there are some but not a lot whereas at
4% starting yield I I can usually find
some companies that are going to raise
the dividend 8% 10% on average over 10
years so it's a little bit easier these
companies that you look are these names
that we would recognize are you looking
at you know like Johnson and Johnson um
uh some yes absolutely I mean a couple
of the companies in my portfolio right
now are AT&T and IBM uh they have huge
yields uh especially AT&T that's that's
been beating up for a while so if if
it's a well-known name like that chances
are it's been beaten up for a little bit
and that's why the yield is high and
that's why I'm willing to to take a
chance and sit with it for uh five seven
10 years but there are plenty of names
that most people have probably NE never
heard of there's a company I recently
recommended called Spartan Nash they are
a um grocery wholesaler and one of their
main clients is the US military
commissaries um it's it's a small cap
company uh has a nice yield good
dividend growth also a little bit beaten
up not every stock I recommended is
beaten up but a lot of them are
especially 10 years into a bull market
uh it's tough to find companies that
have strong yields um if they do have
strong yield chances are it's because
the stock price has not gone as high as
uh you know a lot of their
contemporaries so and are you doing any
options strategies with these to
increase income or is that out of your
model uh not for the Oxford income
letter that's a straight stock buying um
uh
newsletter we do have some trading
services that where we recommend options
but those are more for speculation as
opposed to income but but I do like that
strategy um if you're not planning on
holding a stock for 10 years that's the
other thing too if I'm buying let's say
AT&T and I and I expect it to be and I
think it's a great value right now
they're going to grow their dividend and
and I want to hold it for 10 years I
don't want to write options on it
because I don't want that stock to get
called away from me um so I so that's
one of the main reasons I I won't do
that if if it's a company that I'm not
planning on holding for 10 years that
it's just hey this is a good stock I'm
fine with owning it for a little while
collect the dividend and there's a good
opportunity to write a covered call on
it and if it gets called away no problem
then I think it's a great strategy and I
then I also do like writing puts on uh
on companies that I would like to own at
a lower price but for the opan income
letter um not all of our subscribers are
sophisticated enough to especially write
naked puts so um so this is really just
a stock buying uh service so how many
recommendations will you make how many
companies will you find and recommend
during the course of a year so we try to
do one per month and
um because it's a monthly newsletter so
it really that's that's the goal uh
sometimes there might be more uh usually
not less and then throughout the year
I'm also uh selling some stocks again
the goal is to hold these for a long
time right um but sometimes the
fundamentals change sometimes we'll put
a trailing stop on a stock so that uh if
if something happens uh either in the
markets or the individual stock we don't
take a huge loss uh every every
situation is a little bit different so
uh so we are selling some stocks through
the year but but not a lot I mean really
the goal is to hold hold these for as
long as possible if we can so yeah so
you're not just looking at what's com up
you're still managing your own portfolio
and what what you've recommended in the
past and how oh yeah and and and we're I
send out updates every week on usually
kind of the the structure is every
Thursday I send an email highlighting
one of the companies in the portfolio
and then there's a couple of their
blurbs on some of the other companies um
we also have a mailbag so I get a lot of
questions about hey what's going on with
XYZ um so so we're we're constantly
monitoring and communicating with the
readers what's happening in the
portfolio
if if I want to build a portfolio out of
these stocks over you know the next
couple of years how many should I want
to have it in my port I'm assuming I
need more than one or two yeah it what's
a what's a good portfolio for somebody
um my age I'm at 60 what you know to
have yeah I'd want to see at least 10 um
possibly more if uh you know if you can
handle it and now that actually there
are are most of the Brokers are not
charging commission at least the
discount brokers that's not really a
problem anymore uh you know it doesn't
eat up your your returns so uh 10 15
even 20 um and it kind of depends on the
type of investor you are if you're the
kind of person who's going to watch
every tick uh of your stocks then
keeping track of 20 stocks might be a
little overwhelming if you're the kind
of person who's just going to look at
your statement once a month or look at
the newsletter when it comes out uh then
I think that's a little bit easier but
you do want to have uh you know
diversification uh that's that's a very
common uh recommendation in investing
you want to be Diversified and for me
it's it's not just Diversified among
sectors so it's not just that you want
some energy some technology some Telecom
some healthare you also want
diversification in geography you want
diversification in uh value versus
growth you want diversification in
market cap size you want some small caps
some large caps because there's always
some part of the market that's
outperforming and some part that's
underperforming so you want to always
make sure you have some exposure to
whatever is working and so that's why I
think you want to have at least 10
stocks so you have a little piece of
everything in there any other advice
that you'd give to somebody who is new
to this but but likes the concept yeah I
I think a lot of new investors
are overwhelmed or concerned that this
is really complex and that you have to
be a financial genius to make money in
the markets and you really don't um I
mean if you you have to know how to read
a financial statement if you're going to
do the analysis of a company yourself
but to just invest and make money as I
mentioned markets go up over the long
term we know that yes there are blips
that we had the Great Recession uh that
was painful but it it came back pretty
quickly you made your money back if you
stayed in uh you made your money back
within uh you know in way less than a
decade I I I think it was about five and
a half years so all you have to do is is
invest for the long term be confident
you're going to make money over the long
term because we know markets go up and
as I mentioned earlier again these
dividend companies outperform the
broader market so it is a fairly safe
way of investing and you just have to
keep your eye on the prize of long term
and not get worried every time the
market shakes and shimmies because it
will uh you know great the Great
Recession happened we're going to have
we're going to have run of the the mill
bare markets Great Recession was was
awful and a lot of people still um
bearing the scars of that but we have
General uh you know just general bare
markets that go down 20% and then they
come back and but people even get
freaked out during those periods so if
you can just know that recessions happen
bare markets happen over the long term
if you're invested in good companies at
good values that are raising their
dividends you're going to make money and
you'll probably make a decent amount of
money doing it this way and and just
just don't get scared because that's
that's the easiest thing to do and it's
natural it's natural for people to get
scared when things uh turn South but um
all you have to do is look at the
history and the data and this is you
know not recent data this is going back
uh to the early part of the 1900s that
that we know that these markets go up
over the long term in doing these
interviews I've interviewed a a number
of editors of of newsletters and that
was you know some of that was new to me
I didn't realize there's this much
information out there and and basically
an industry providing um in information
for people to control their own
Investments compare that for me with
somebody who who's just been advised you
know put your money in a in a mutual
fund and let right and ignore it and
check on it every few years well it it
depends on who's told you to put the
money in the mutual fund if it's your
broker your full full service broker
then you need to understand why he's
recommending in that particular mutual
fund is he getting a commission on it is
The Brokerage paying a bonus for uh for
sales into that mutual fund uh you know
there there are some Brokers there are
plenty of brokers who really do
everything they can to do right by their
clients and then there are plenty of
Brokers that are trying to make as much
money as they can for themselves so you
have to question that if you're talking
about let's say um you know investing
some index funds that's a perfectly
reasonable way way to invest especially
if you are going to be kind of a set it
and forget it investor put your money in
a bunch of Vanguard index funds they're
cheap and they're going to perform in
line with the market uh over the long
term and that and that's fine you'll
you'll do well over the long term if you
want to do better than in line with the
market if you want to beat the market
then I think you want unbiased advice
you want people who know what they're
talking about who are not incentivized
to make any specific recommendations uh
you know we do not accept compensation
for many companies to recommend their
stocks um we're not allowed to own the
stocks that we recommend so it's not
like I'm getting to some small cap and
hoping I can get 10,000 readers to buy
it um so it's it's very unbiased uh
research and the only way we make money
is if our subscribers are happy and
renew their subscriptions so um you know
I think you always want to question
where you're getting your information
and what the motivation is for the
person making that recommendation I'm
delighted that you uh are doing what
you're doing um not saying you wouldn't
have been a great sports caster but uh I
I know this helps a ton of people thank
you very much oh thank you for having me
I appreciate it to see the next episode
in the wealth breakthrough series check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the wealthiest aren't
always the happiest but they're the
freest they had the ability to move
wherever they need to go or do whatever
they need to do they had the ability to
quit a jobs they don't like their boss
they can go on vacation here versus
there